Guten morgen linos.
Guten morgen tim.
Das ist jetzt nicht mehr mit truppen.
Uschi.
Logbuch netz politik nummer dreihundertacht vom siebzehnten juli zweitausendneunzehn.
Und was haben wir gestern gefiltert ne.
Was hast du.
Hab ich ich habe ja ich habe da gesessen und auf reload gedrückt hier kommen sag mal wie sieht das aus ne und stellt sich raus haben wir da irgendwie neun zehn leute haben wahrscheinlich wieder falschen knopf gedrückt genauso wie bei den upload filtern.
Nachher wie achso er war schon kommissionspräsident innen war jetzt nehme ich habe mich wurde nachher korrigiert ist auch tatsächlich dass das haben sie auf papier gemacht.
Gut so kommen wir noch zu dieser problematik.
Die problematik des.
Genau knopfdruck und die andere problematik wird uns jetzt längere zeit beschäftigen sie heißt kommissionspräsident hin,
von der leyen.
Geht noch nicht so richtig verletzungen ne.
Ne es gab ja eigentlich es gab ja hoffnung sie hat ja ursprünglich dann angekündigt dass sie egal wie die wahl am,
dienstag ausgeht sie am mittwoch also heute das amt der verteidigungsministerin niederlagen würde.
Und ich habe mich gefreut weil ich dachte es ist die erste möglichkeit mit einer klappe,
zweimal die gleiche fliege zu schlagen indem man sie einfach nicht wählt ja aber nein wurde natürlich gewählt und die neue verteidigungsministerin ist jetzt.
Du ich weiß ich weiß ich was ich mir so vorstellen ich traue mich gar nicht zu fragen ne wenn du so wenn du jetzt in deutschland sage ich mal für einen.
Sagen wir mal ein paar jahrzehnte dich in so einem liberal links liberal feministische,
geiste engagiert hast ne und blickst dann so du kriegst jetzt diese feministische erfolge ja unter die nase gerieben so guck mal hier wir haben
die erste eu-kommission präsident hingestellt guck mal wenn erste bundeskanzlerin
gestellt und wir haben auch ne die wahrscheinlich zweite schon die zweite verteidigungsministerin hier gestellt und,
ich stelle so gerade vor für die ganzen also das ist glaube ich nicht nicht schön zu ertragen wenn wenn einem denn sowas auf der nase gerieben wird und als als irgendwie,
der braucht gar kein minister zwischen engagement da brauchst du gar nicht ne guck mal wir haben hier schon das läuft ja hier alles super solange du irgendwie,
sämtliche,
wenn du so lange durch sämtlichen prinzipien der cdu unterordnen ist und sie lebst kannst du auch als frau eins a hier was werden das ist schon echt glaube ich schmerzhaft gerade für viele.
Das ist doch ne karrierechancen die sich die feministin wahrscheinlich so nie ausgemalt hat.
Ja gleichstellung schon aber doch nicht so.
Yeah.
Naja meckern wenn man nicht zu früh da gibt es sicherlich später noch genug gelegenheit vielleicht hat das ja auch irgendwas gutes wird jetzt ein bisschen daher was natürlich ein bisschen.
Beunruhigend ist es wäre ihre anfälligkeit gegenüber so aber die kinder populismus ja nun schon zu genüge kennengelernt haben.
Und wenn das dann sozusagen die tolle leitlinie ist für weitere verschärfung von über recht et cetera dann wird der kampf an der stelle sicherlich nicht einfacher.
Die kinder müssen weiter geschützt werden da fällt mir da fällt uns eine anekdote ein die ich erzählen muss dich erzählen muss und zwar ähm.
In meinem freundes-
Wieder was mit russen.
Nee mit kindern.
Diesmal nur mit kindern diesmal diesmal nur mit kindern aber auch mit hackern also kriegt das set also familie hat zwei kinder.
Die kinder sind elf und neun jahre alt und unterliegen einem,
unterliegen limitationen in der nutzung des ipads zum spiele spielen na kannst du irgendwie keine ahnung da gibt's ja diese eltern konstanz die du da einfügen kannst oder so.
Guten tag.
Mit solchen scherze ich glaube die haben aber auch ich bin mir nicht sicher die hatten das war glaube ich gar nicht deren ipad auf jeden fall.
Näherte sich in der familie der verdacht dass die kinder den ipad code irgendwie kennen um das ding zu anlocken,
ja und es wurde erstmal so dann einfach gesagt naja ändern wir mal den code und man merkt irgendwie so ne am unruhe level und unzufriedenheit level der kinder merkte man so die kanten,
seid ihr jetzt anders ist blicken die irgendwie nicht mehr so hoffnungsvoll aufs leben ne die haben irgendwie so zukunft ängste machen klatsch bei jeder gelegenheit 'ne essen nicht
zanken sich und so eine typische phänomen von dem irgendwo im zugang verloren der,
wichtig war und dann kommt also der.
Zur mutter in einer in einer stresssituation säuberlich ausgeblendet ja also beeindruckendes level an manager in diesem jungen schafft also genauso eine situation so,
mutter muss grad aus dem haus hat schon den hat schon die schuhe an sucht noch den schlüssel ist zu spät dran ne mama ich muss noch mal ganz kurz hier an die notizen app
für die schule was neues aufschreiben kannst du mir ganz kurz das ipad entsperren kriegst du auch sofort wieder kannst du mitnehmen oder so irgendwie er muss nur an die not
und hält ihr quasi das ipad hin und.
Und sie macht das hat ihn in der hand und in dem moment fängt das zweite kind das jüngere an irgendwelchen totalen scheiß zu reden übrigens immer mein tipp schnauze halten,
schnauze halten ist immer,
und fängt an irgendwelchen dumm kram zu reden und die mutter denkt ihr stimmt doch irgendwas nicht ne warum redet meine tochter auf einmal so ein stuss in dieser situation wo ich jetzt hier diesen code eingeben soll und guckt nochmal in ruhe das ipad an.
Und sieht oben links in der ecke in dem ipad neben der uhr einen roten punkt.
Und denkt sich jetzt in der rote punkt tippt auf den roten punkt und das,
willst du die bildschirm aufzeichnung jetzt beenden geiler hacker muss ich wirklich sagen so.
Aufzeichnung funktioniert auch bei der pin eingabe.
Gehe davon aus dass das dass sie quasi gestartet wurde zu einem weil diese pin eingabe ja nur für apps ist und nicht für das ipad selber.
Also es ist ja dieses potential control oder sowas ne und dann kannst du sagen ok die und die app ist freigegeben aber alle anderen nicht und ja bildschirm aufzeichnung.
Die kämpfen mit allen mitteln.
Auch auf face id bringt da immer wieder neue spielarten dass sie haben einfach so im richtigen moment einfach mal das teil.
Und es wurde auch erzählt ja die haben dann gesagt als sie ihn dann quasi damit erwischt haben hat er hat die typische reaktion eines eines hackern gezeigt und meinte so okay,
den kennt er ich habe aber noch ein,
dann hat sich da nicht weiter dazu geäußert und in einer anderen in einer anderen familie gibt es auch diese situation da war das so,
supergeil sohn hat einen.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das ipad war oder eine i phone also auch so ein gerät mit control drauf also und
die mutter scheiß vergessen was natürlich auch
nur so ein geiles friedens situation ist weil er jetzt irgendwie so geil ich habe kann ich eine halbe stunde am tag benutzen weil meine mutter verfluchten code nicht mehr kennt.
Und er hat dann auch irgendwie,
sich dann auch arrangiert und er hat dann auch irgendwie im internet einen weg gefunden dass das zu umgehen weiß der geier wer das gemacht hat ob er das telefon wiederhergestellt hat weiß also ich kann 's mir auch wieder nicht vorstellen weil finde wiederherstellung müsstest du ja.
Beleidigt und so weiter eingeben.
Irgendwas so und ja aber die kinder also passt auf.
Passt auf mit den kindern ursula von der leyen wird da sicherlich bald eine eine lösung für,
vorschlagen irgendwie so eine freiwillige selbstverpflichtung der kinder oder so mal gucken was wir da noch so haben aber das fand ich sehr schön.
Genau und zwar irgendeine wo dann im fünften neben artikel insgesamt gesetzesvorhaben es mal eben nochmal die dauer von irgendwie hundert auf dreihundert jahre erhöht wird weil micky maus.
Sommer zum feedback kommen.
Wir machen gab's welches.
Es gab viel feedback hin es gab viel.
Per e-mail per kommentar.
Weil wir haben uns sehr widerlich politisch korrekt fallen.
Weiß ich nicht ich finde wir hatten schon politisch korrekt wir verhalten uns politisch kriegt aber manuel schreibt uns per e-mail der zum thema libra
der haupteingang und ist facebook erschließt mit kaliber a eine weitere quelle für den zugriff auf persönliche daten eine quelle die ihnen bisher nicht zur verfügung stand jetzt kann facebook sagen
wir respektieren die privatsphäre wir aggregieren die transaktion staaten nicht mit den anderen daten die wir ohnehin schon haben,
aber geben davon auch nichts an dritte weiter aber bei dem track von facebook darf man da sehr sehr skeptisch sein.
Klaus kommentierte darauf aufbauend man stelle sich bloß mal vor das ding maus hat sich zum allgemeinen akzeptieren globalen zahlungsmittel.
Ob und womit der coin dann am ende hinterlegt wird lässt sich im zweifel durch ein update der nutzung richtlinien anpassen,
das ist schon also da hat ein punkt das irgendwie währungs-
Währungen schon anderen ideen unterliegen als nah als nennen als den agb's eines unternehmen wo wo das am ende immer sagt wer du musst ja nicht muss ja nicht mitmachen bei uns.
Dann kommentiert julian.
Thema anbelangt libra et cetera das klima ich bin ein wenig beißt weil mein unternehmen selbst in diesem bereich arbeitet was an band in,
entwicklungsländern konkret bedeutet ist dass menschen mitunter einen tag im monat frei nehmen drei stunden zur nächsten bank laufen oder fahren dort weitere drei stunden anstehen und dann wieder heim fahren nur um ihr gehalt.
Zum beispiel bei staats bedienstete wie lehrern oder andere gelder subventionen rente etcetera abzuholen überweisungen sind in diesen ländern fast unmöglich beziehungsweise sau teuer weil sie über migranten
usa oder so abgewickelt werden müssen das problem fällt gibt es durchaus und ich kenne,
ländern südostasien uns das konzept privatsphäre ist oftmals überhaupt nicht vorhanden was viele verschiedene gründe hat von niedriger bildungsstand bis zu der art und weise wie die gesellschaften dort überhaupt funktionieren dass facebook,
so etwas anbietet ist für die leute super prima jetzt aber kommt der knackpunkt,
nicht nur würden die leute massiv abhängig von facebook werden es würde auch eine noch größere schere zwischen arm in klammer klammern hat nur feature von und reich kann sich smartphone leisten entstehen und auch wenn günstige smartphones sagen wir mal für dreißig bis fünfzig dollar verfügbar sind ist das für viele substanz fahrerin
im hinterland eines entwicklungsland des immernoch ein knappes monatseinkommen aber viel wichtiger entsteht.
Noch eine größere stadt land schere weil du dich nicht auf einen bezahlt system verlassen kannst dass nur dann funktioniert wenn das internet auch läuft das wiederum bedeutet kein netz,
kein mittagessen ich kenne jetzt persönlich das land ost timur sehr gut dort kann man mit ausreichender zuverlässigkeit sagen ob es gerade regnet indem man die internetverbindung prüft verbindung tot gleich regen,
und dieses problem nimmt mit der abgelegenen seit der leute zu.
Können wir ja auch aus deutschland.
Das kennen wir aus deutschland auch also regen regen nicht bei uns fällt das netz meistens schon vorher aus,
insofern diese zuverlässigkeit haben wir einfach nicht in deutschland ne das problem nicht mit der ab gelegenheit der leute zu,
dann hat mal der mobilfunk muss kein strom in der regenzeit ist das internet ist schlecht et cetera pp das sah an irgendwelche satelliten oder ballroom projekte groß etwas ändern werden daran zweifel ich sehe.
Der trick bei,
in pizza ist übrigens mal abgesehen davon was für technische probleme hat das ist sogenannte managements gibt also leute die dir dein mobilfunk guthaben in bargeld umwandeln das müsste ein lieber basierte lokales bezahlt system in diesen ländern
also auch noch mit sich bringen setzt sich lieber also durch befürchte ich dass die ärmsten der armen noch weiter abgehängt.
Da ist jetzt auch viel zweifel drin ich denke generell werden wir einfach eine weitere verbreitung von internet sehen über welche technologien auch immer da kann man natürlich skeptisch sein aber das ist jetzt schlechter wird sehe ich halt auch nicht,
und er beschreibt ja eigentlich auch sehr schön wo das problem derzeit ist das also einfach diese ganzen standards.
Geld ströme derzeit einfach noch durch 'ne sehr kleine zahl von geldgebern läuft und alles was da weitere option anbietet verbessert meiner meinung nach tendenziell erstmal die situation.
Psa was dann halt wirklich auf es ist sieben also quasi da auf telekom intern extension also nicht deutsche unternehmens infrastruktur in afrika ist es soweit ich weiß vor allem,
vodafone basiert.
Muss letztlich auch durch irgendwas abgelöst werden und wird sich wahrscheinlich ohnehin automatisch auch ins internet entwickeln und da ist halt lieber dann ein weiterer konkurrent.
So
klar musst du halt immer noch irgendwie umtauschen so es denn noch bargeld bedarf gibt und die frage ist halt ist ein einzahlung system ein elektronisches zahlung system auch irgendwann mal in der lage innerhalb seines eigenen zahlungs kosmos
die dienstleistung zu bieten also wenn ich mit apple pay zahlen kann wo quasi meint die weiß eine transaktion,
über das normale separat system beziehungsweise kreditkarten auslöst dann könnte ich mir genauso gut auch eine lösung auf dem smartphone vorstellen die das halt mit libra macht wo dann halt wirklich libra auf libra,
konnten fließt direkt wo halt quasi den zunehmenden maße bargeld was ja auch noch andere probleme mit sich bringt,
also in diesen ländern sauberkeit et cetera,
überhaupt auch da die stabilität der lokalen währung wo ja quasi libra auch anders abgesichert.
Bevor ich wieder missverstanden werde ich bin weit davon entfernt das jetzt irgendwie über den grünen zu loben ich sag mal,
so so ist es und man da ehrlich gesagt seht da durchaus möglichkeiten dass es einen gewissen teil erfolg haltung hat und ich denke dass sehr viel mehr.
Und weniger von seinen technischen sondern.
Dann darf natürlich wenn wir über lieber reden nicht fehlen dass deine,
nicht vollständige würdigung von kritisiert wird da kommentiert christian hat eine eigene v m ist deshalb nicht an bestimmte programmiersprache gebunden smart contract kann man,
nicht,
in javascript programmiert die aktuell propagiert populär erste sprache solidität wurde anfangs als javascript ähnlich vermarktet sie ist sie doch stark
typisiert und hat bis auf die cd artige sonntags nichts mit javascript gemein.
Hat auch eine stabile werbung währung den kurs durch verschiedene mechanismen bei zirka ein us-dollar gehalten wird anfangs war geplant sich nicht am,
us d sondern am ber zu orientieren das wurde aber denke ich aus praktika militär
gründen verworfen außerdem plant schon von anfang an den profi durch einen anderen mechanismus zu ersetzen der nicht sicher aber günstiger ist dazu soll im nächsten jahr der erste schritt gemacht werden also auch dort,
fortschritt.
Was ist denn.
Du fragst immer die sachen über die versuche kurz hinweg zu bügeln.
Na ja ich meine wenn wir das jetzt hier sagen.
Software die find radio.
Bestimmt nicht nicht dollar sondern.
Special.
Währung seine.
Aber das ist nicht schwächer dieses das asset der die.
Ja das ist offenbar dass.
Ja die international reserve asset kontext ja nach dem brand award sting also.
Die haben doch die haben doch irgendwann gesagt sie binden den äh sie bin den us-dollar nicht mehr an gold hinterlegen die nicht mehr in gold und dann gibt's du halt irgendwie so eine so eine standard rate verglichen einer.
Verglichen das geld und das ist das special right.
Okay also eine künstliche währung die nicht an den division märkten gehandelt wird sondern auf der da steigt mein wissen über banksystem und.
Der wert des ist ein gemischter korb aus fünf währungen der us-dollar dem euro dem chinesischen rennen mindi dem japanischen jan und dem britischen fund.
Okay
gut also hier steht auch er schreibt ja dann auch noch schon vorgelesen das puff ja ersetzt werden soll okay gut also dann haben sie da ähnliche ideen und es wird da sicherlich nochmal in die competition gehen man sieht auf jeden fall dass die
kryptowährung schon probleme damit haben quasi ihre diesen starken währung schwankungen ausgesetzt zu sein wenn man sich halt,
als alternative präsentieren will zu den bisherigen währungen muss man in irgendeiner form sich trotzdem zu ihnen definiert verhalten.
Dann andre da habe ich schon mitgerechnet weil wir am ende der unser zensur hatte ich dann doch
minimale gedächtnis lücken hinsicht hinsichtlich der umsetzung hatte und der andere hat damals seine masterarbeit über das gesamte theater geschrieben deswegen wusste ich dass wir uns da
auf die sprünge helfen wird andere schreibt kleine korrektur zum zensur oder teil das gesetz hat
der damalige bundespräsident köder als bundespräsident damals unterzeichnet es gab nur eine bundestagswahl bis es in kraft treten sollte die union fand sich mit der fdp in der regierung die das gesetz blöd fand
also die fdp dann erging der erwähnte nicht anwendungen verlass sinngemäß
hey bka das gesetz verlangt dass ihr eine liste von webseiten an provider liefern müsst tut das einfach nicht.
Und es wurde ein neues gesetz gebastelt mit dem das zensur solar gesetz entfernt wurde.
Und achso und stattdessen die aufgabe gegeben wurde doch mal die hosting provider zu finden bei denen die gefundenen webseiten betrieben werden stellt sich raus löschen geht doch wenn man,
nicht nur sperrt also der satz war für mich etwas schwer zu lesen würde quasi zensur zensur datei weg stattdessen hausaufgabe findet die hosting provider und,
löscht.
Sensor da wurde damals übrigens nicht sofort kriegst ministerin das war zuerst noch kalte oder filme wilhelm von uns zu und guten flug und hast du nicht gesehen sondern arbeitsministerium ein weil sie auch nochmal.
Schmunzeln nebenbei zweitausendneun kritisierten hinterbänkler der cdu csu ein spd beschluss mit dem argument im internet gäbe es böse dinge,
bis hin zu urheberrechtsverletzungen lustig ist das wenn man bemerkt dass die csu.
Da von einer dorothee bär vertreten wird was macht die inzwischen eigentlich so.
Tja.
Ja andere das ist danke danke dass du uns noch mal vor augen führt dass es doch alles noch ein bisschen schlimmer ist als ist und war als wir es in erinnerung hatten danke das ist sehr schön.
Gab es noch ein feedback von saal rita an dich tim.
Tim den vergleich gallasch es dorf für die fusion finde ich nicht so passend nazis,
gibt es auch in den großen deutschen städten mehr als genug und die leute um die fusion drumherum haben sich ja mehrheitlich für das projekt und gegen die polizeipräsident,
präsenz polizeipräsident mehr raus und den rechten traum von recht und ordnung ausgesprochen ansonsten coole sende sendungen danke und schönen sommer euch,
ja wenn wir haben vielen dank der rita.
Ein gültiger punkt ich meinte es halt eher vielleicht mal das beispiel nicht das beste halt so,
in einer gesamtsituation wenn man jetzt mal über den unmittelbaren anwohner kreis hinausgeht ist es halt jetzt nicht.
Unbedingt bei die volksfreund des land alles.
Das das ist richtig das ist nirgendwo so ich finde das wird noch über sanitas kommentar etwas hinzu hinzufügen oder ich nicht unbedingt hinausgehen zu führen es wäre auch nicht das einzige
der eins das einzige nest des widerstandes jetzt unbedingt lehrt es gibt viele.
Strukturen die in den ländlichen regionen mecklenburg-vorpommerns aufgebaut werden und dort irgendwie positive
gesellschafts form ausprobieren etablieren und aufbauen und sie alle verdienen und benötigen unsere unterstützung,
und das fand ich übrigens sehr schön bei der fusion hat auch feine sahne fischfilet gespielt und der sänger sagt er dann auch irgendwann zwischendurch sinngemäß.
Sowas wie,
er lobt sich doch die leute die in mv bleiben und dort finde für eine ordentliche gesellschaft einstehen und kämpfen statt sich nach kreuzberg und sankt pauli zu verpissen fand ich,
haben wir alle applaudiert als kreuzberger und paul jana hat einen punkt natürlich hilft auch nichts wenn wir da uns alle verpissen weil dann werden diese region und strukturen.
Diesen höcke spinnen überlassen und eigentlich ist es ja ein leichtes,
muss ich immer wieder sagen zu zeigen wie ein ordentliches schönes zusammenleben.
Vonstatten geht wenn man es einfach macht das ist einfachste ist einfach vor zu leben.
Ist aber jetzt auch ein bisschen einfach einzeln sozusagen da die flucht vorzuwerfen.
Na weil man weiß ja nicht in in welchen konkreten situationen sind diese angetreten haben und wenn du halt irgendwie nur noch umbringt bis von von hirn toten.
Die dir jeden tag das leben zur hölle machen dann denkst du halt auch so ich muss jetzt hier nicht die revolution ausrufen ich gehe einmal damit ich überhaupt erstmal klarkommen und wer einen klaren gedanken.
Und ich glaube das ist aber schon sanitas punkt das ist nicht so ist dass du dann nur umringt bis von hirn toten ja das ähm.
Jedes aber wir wissen auch dass es solche situationen gibt so dass das halt.
Twitter zum beispiel.
Ja gespannt weil wir ja auch eine sachliche ebene kommen in dieser sendung heute.
So und dann noch ein das ist das ist gar nicht unbedingt feedback aber irgendwie auch schon ihr erinnert euch als wir über das thema,
lausche angriff über alexa sprachen hier in der sendung das war zur innenminister rinnen konferenz oder ist innenministerkonferenz ist wirklich 'ne innenministerkonferenz ne das ist 'ne innenministerkonferenz.
Was soll das seine.
Ihr könnt ja auch eine innen ministerinnen konferenz sein aber aber das ist eine innenminister konferenz ne die haben.
Achso in der innenminister doppelpunkt in den konferenz das wäre doch mal schön.
Da steht doch schon ihnen.
Wir haben noch das eben schon vorne braucht man da die nochmal.
Aber außenminister innen ist es ganz wichtig oder innenminister aus.
Die sternchen minister konferenz.
Also da gab es eine kleine anfrage der fdp-fraktion.
Und haben gesagt ja wie stellt sich das die bundesregierung denn vor mit dem abhören von alexa und er antwortet die bundesregierung.
Sinngemäß dass sie nicht die auffassung vertritt dass es sich bei denen in rede stehenden vernetzten geräten um eine neue geräte klasse handeln würde die vom bestehenden rechtsrahmen nicht.
Fast sei das ist das habe ich vor einigen folgen auch gesagt als als die sternchen minister.
Sie sagen sie sind der meinung dass es eine das ist so.
Es ist keine neue geräte klasse ist ein informationsveranstaltung system und.
Also her damit.
Da sagen sie immerhin also für den wohl weiter aus dass sie eine online durchsuchung dafür.
Für angemessen halten ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher die haben immer noch nicht verstanden dass das ding halt die die daten nicht auf dem gerät liegen sondern in in der cloud aber immerhin.
In einem punkt,
behalte ich recht sie haben also es war niemals geplant oder niemals ernsthaft in erwägung gezogen dass sie neue gesetzliche rahmen brauchen um diese daten,
zu bekommen da sind sie fest überzeugt dass sie das schon,
haben sondern dass es ihnen darum ging die technischen möglichkeiten aufzubauen damit auch umzugehen das heißt das wir haben jetzt hier.
Eigentlich eine vermengen von lausche angriff und online durchsuchung.
Beide für beide braucht es einen richterlichen beschluss,
und das geht nur bei besonders schweren straftaten aber ich denke hier wird es auch früher oder später auf jeden fall wieder in richtung karlsruhe gehen weil diese,
vermengen von okay wir dürfen computer hacken zu.
Es sind in jedem computer in jedem gerät was du hast computer drin und diese geräte haben unterschiedliche,
eigenschaften wie sie mit dir interagieren und es entspricht nicht mehr dem zeitpunkt zudem dieses gesetz geschrieben wurde was irgendwie online durchsuchung sowas angehen und ich habe mich natürlich.
Nicht nur einmal hab ich da die stellungnahmen auch von konstant zu kurz und anderen c vertretern gelesen die sich mit,
den thematiken staatsstraße jane online durchsuchung und so weiter auseinander gesetzt haben war das vom bundesverfassungsgericht in den unterschiedlichen ausschüssen und so weiter und ich muss immer sagen da war
zur damaligen zeit zusammen wir zehn jahre oder was das jetzt her ist ne da erschienen die.
Erschienen diese äußerungen noch ein bisschen ich will mal sagen,
esoterisch oder so ne also bisschen ja die computer das sind unsere erweiterten gehirne in dem bildet sich der kern unserer privaten lebensführung ab und so weiter und das lasse ich damals immer noch alles so ein bisschen so wie
also zu einer zeit wo du halt noch ein club laptop mit zwei stunden batterielaufzeit unten rum laufwerk hat es ne war das halt so auch so ein bisschen so ja genau
so in.
Stanislav mäßig.
Ja so du warst so voll irgendwie so auf irgendwie ganz fiction und zehn jahre später,
so jetzt mal grob siehst du genau das,
jetzt ist allen klar was was sie was wir auf einmal für schöne geräte haben ne mit die mit uns sprechen aus der cloud und was da alles was da alles gekommen ist in so einer kurzen zeit und da kann man natürlich jetzt sagen da war das dieser text,
hat sich esser gezeigt dass der gar nicht gar nicht mal so visionär war,
im sinne von ich rede von einer zukunft von in zwanzig dreißig jahren sondern eigentlich eine zukunft beschrieben hat von in fünf jahren,
oder in in acht jahren vielleicht vom zeitpunkte schreibt und da musste ich nochmal sehr daran denken wenn ihr wenn ihr jetzt hier diese debatte hast.
Alles klar effektiv.
Eine eindringen in wohnraum kernbereich der lebensführung über online durchsuchung weil sich eben jetzt ganz andere,
aspekte unseres lebens auch auf computern abbilden wo damals noch irgendwie so das phänomen war die leute haben computer sie schreiben damit e-mails,
da müssen sie kein porto für bezahlen das funktioniert durchs weltweite netz und es geht sogar bis hin zu urheberrechtsverletzungen,
was mit diesen maschinen inzwischen möglich ist das.
Ja man muss sich glaube ich so ein bisschen trennen von diesem von dieser,
mittlerweile fast klassischen vorstellung dass du der computer quasi so der nachfolger des vollständig büros ist,
dass es so der arbeitsort ist wo die dokumente verfasst werden das was die privatsphäre ausmacht.
Bildet sich quasi,
über alles was elektronisch ist in irgendeiner form ab weil alles vernetzt ist weil alles geteilt ist weil alles seine eigenen lok bücher anlegt und das haares ding das auswerten aller dieser daten,
bietet eben,
eine extreme masse an an untersuchungshaft trial gar nicht mehr jetzt nur für kriminologe nachforschungen sondern halt wenn du einfach überhaupt mal wissen willst wie irgendjemand drauf ist,
und ja dem den muss man sich jetzt stellen und bestimmte bedrohen szenarien werden dadurch halt nicht unrealistisch.
Und vor allem die die konsequenzen für die gesellschaft ne ich finde was ich auch noch ganz interessant finde ist der computer ne.
Wie lange reden wir denn wie lange werden wir noch sagen es sind überall computer drin.
Oder wie wird das dann irgendwann zu selbstverständlich ist der computer drin aber das also das.
Wie viel computer ist.
Wie viel computer oder oder oder auch so ein bisschen dieses wieder ist doch kein computer drin ein computer ist ein großes gerät mit einer tastatur das ist da nicht drin das ist ja nur ein gerät,
ja also das ist ja also dass sich quasi letztendlich das durchsetzen dass das ist kein computer das ist einfach nur.
Gerät klar das kann rechnen überträgt daten hat irgendwie funktionalitäten wie ein computer und das funktioniert ähnlich den computer,
so wie man halt sagen würde das ist ein besteck ne aber das ist jetzt nicht jedem jedes messer ist eine gabel weißt du was ich meine.
Ja also sagen wir mal so man muss umdrehen und sagen welches gerät ist überhaupt noch keinen computer oder anders formuliert computer sind.
Eins einer.
Nein jedes also wenn du heute sagst gerät dann nimmt man eigentlich schon impliziert an,
dass es auf computer basis funktioniert weil ich muss jetzt ehrlich gesagt schon ganz schön lange überlegen
es ist mir so geräte meinem haushalt einfallen wo tatsächlich kein computer drin ist dass es vielleicht so 'ne orangen presse oder irgendwie sowas so küchen geräte und bei leibe halt auch nicht
alle.
Orangen presse die hat keine wifi oder was.
Nee nicht mal blutwurst.
Boah der ist ist der spahn.
Finde ich es anders.
Echt ohne ohne kraft anzeige ohne nicht mal instagram integration oder so.
Speichert auch nicht meinen kalorien verbraucht weil der benutzung des gerätes äh wirklich armselig.
Tja rückständig.
Was ist das denn drückst du irgendwie deine deine orange offen runden stein oder.
Aber so ein thermomix wiederum weiß ganz genau was du dir zubereitet hast so.
Ich habe kein thermomix das ist nicht dieses thermomix thema anfang ich habe.
Ich will kein thermomix thema anfangen ich sag nur auch in der küche besonders wirklich und auch dieser sagenumwobenen vernetzte kühlschrank ja weiß wann du die tür aufgemacht hast und wenn du sie zu gemacht hast oder kann es zumindest wissen und wird es wissen und was weiß.
Wenn du fragst wann bin ich so dick geworden wird ja die genau sagen pass auf kann ich dir gedacht.
Ist auf jeden fall extrem schwer mit einem durchschnittlich ausgestattet technisch ausgestatteten haushalt heutzutage keinerlei intensive daten spur anzulegen sehr sehr sehr schwierig.
Übrigens doktor einen schönen vortrag gehalten achtundzwanzig zu drei dem city kongress vor einigen jahren unter dem titel und generell computing.
Wie immer sehr visionär und.
Achtundzwanzig.
Kennst du ne berlin.
C
und der steve jobs hat damals dieses dieses schöne zeit diesen schönen vergleich gebracht zwischen was was computer überhaupt,
und die meisten leute brauchen halt nur einen kleinwagen und das wird mir immer wieder das wird mir immer wieder bewusst wenn ich den computer als arbeitsgerät,
kaufe und sehe dass es immer mehr menschen gibt die sagen ich habe gar keinen computer.
Ich glaube nicht dass irgendwann vielleicht so die die historiker zurückblicken da hatte jeder mensch ein computer zu hause quatsch die an ein gerät mit dem konnte man rechnen.
Naja bleiben wir erstmal noch im in der unmittelbaren gegenwart.
Denn es sieht danach aus dass zensur solar.
Soll das vielleicht bleiben vielleicht kann zensur solar ihren namen behalten,
ja also sie trägt ihn ja jetzt auch schon seit guten zehn jahren.
Und bei netzwerk ort wurde jetzt veröffentlicht ein ein arbeitsparlament hier der eu-kommission klar das war jetzt zu einer zeit da war sie hatte der eu-kommission noch nicht mal wirklich,
vor gestanden aber die plant ein neues digitale dienste gesetz das,
die haftungs- und sicherheitsrat für digitale plattformen dienste und produkte erweitern soll das sagt quasi ihr,
konzept agenda für europa und die ideen die da drin stehen.
Stammen aus einem arbeitsplatz hier was ungefähr sieben seiten umfasst und wahrscheinlich schon vor einiger zeit geschrieben wurde also die die,
die eu-kommission als solche ist ja ein großes gebäude in dem viele menschen arbeiten und nicht alle davon werden ausgewechselt nur weil neue leute reinkommen selbstverständlich bleiben wenn
wenn irgendwie ein unternehmen einen neuen vorstand bekommt dann werden ja auch nicht alle leute gefeuert sondern die müssen weiterarbeiten.
Ist ja auch in jedem ministerium.
Genau ist in jedem ministeriums und die eu-kommission plant quasi schon,
den umbau der e-commerce richtlinie das interessante e-commerce richtlinie haben wir seit ungefähr zwanzig jahren dieser jetzt umgebaut werden in ein digitales dienste gesetz also den digital service,
digital services act und auf dem bezieht sich hier von der leyen ist,
geht es um genau dieses thema notes and take was wir in der letzten sendung auch behandelt haben und gerade auch nochmal in den kommentar von andre wo es eben darum geht wenn,
ein illegaler inhalt auf einer plattform landet dann sind,
unter bestimmten voraussetzungen die plattform betreiber nicht verantwortlich für die uploads die dort stattfinden und werden sie aber darauf aufmerksam gemacht.
Dann sind sie quasi in dem moment wo sie darüber.
Kenntnis erlangt haben dafür verantwortlich und müssen sie deswegen auch entfernen beziehungsweise auch haftbar.
Es heißt das illegale passiert du weißt es nicht deswegen bist du auch nicht schuld du wirst du erlangst darüber kenntnis in dem moment der oder langsam von kenntnis in dem moment musste ran.
Und dieses prinzip hat zwanzig jahre im prinzip dazu geführt dass sich das internet entwickeln konnte
das hier überhaupt etwas passieren konnte das plattform entstehen konnten,
in der breite und in der form wie wir sie heute haben ob das nun gut ob das gute plattform sind oder schlechte plattform es war quasi der aufwand für notes entdeckt und skaliert hier quasi mit einer plattform mit sodass du eben,
ordentlich arbeiten könntest wir haben das sehr häufig behandelt in den letzten wochen und monaten als es um die uploadfilter.
Und in diesem papier dem digital services eck steht auch wieder drin so ja notes ins take ist der grundpfeiler des internets und dann kommt aber.
Man müsste sich natürlich überlegen wie dieser haftungs- ausschluss auf cloud und
an andere internet dienste gestaltet werden muss und das ziel soll also sein plattform betreiber zu proaktiven maßnahmen,
zu ermutigen was ist also jetzt 'ne 'ne proaktive maßnahme.
Und das kann natürlich eigentlich nur sein,
ne irgendetwas automatisches weil wenn du dir die upload mengen die heute in so eine so eine plattform reingehen werden.
Anschaust dann ist natürlich klar denn manuell wird das nicht gehen also proaktiv heißt automatisch.
Wobei facebook schon noch heerscharen von leuten beschäftigt die sich ihre mentalen zustände ruinieren dem sich den ganzen schuld anschauen müssen der hochgeladen.
Ja das ist genau gibt's auch.
Gibt es auch dass es eine.
Eine sicherlich nicht sicherlich nicht besonders schönes phänomen,
und wir können natürlich auch sicher sein dass facebook hier sehr aktiv daran arbeitet das zu diese prozesse zu verbessern.
Verbessern im sinne von weniger menschen damit zu belasten und die prozesse effiziente auszuführen ist aber nochmal ein ganz anderer schnack ob es gesetzlich vorgeschrieben ist.
Und das war die die diskussion um uploadfilter das war effektiv auch so ein bisschen die diskussion um zensur solar- und.
Da können wir uns also können wir vorsichtig drauf blicken ob das nicht dann sogar in der richtung weitergehen.
Also zumindest ist hier nicht unbedingt jetzt die personalie mit der man das gefühl hat es könnte in der nächsten legislatur dort in einer abschwächung dieser regelung geben es sich,
aber was der geier welchen welchen wandel sie jetzt nimmt jetzt von ihrer.
Problematik vielleicht ganz neue segeln auf.
Meinst du das kann jetzt nochmal so nordische metapher.
Das wär doch mal was ist ja sowas verloren gegangen mit den piraten.
Ja das stimmt verloren gegangen ist es ja nicht wir haben ja jetzt nochmal den piraten da sitzen in.
Stimmt ja auch im zensur salat t-shirt da saß ich hab nur so ein foto gesehen wo er dann aber das zensur sondern nicht zu sehen sein dass er dann wirklich so aus also patrick breyer wirklich mit so einem,
auch noch in so einer beten pose und wie nach oben schaute und ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt unbedingt das foto gewesen ist auf das ab gezielt hat naja.
Stream of lautet das nächste thema ja.
Gut ist das okay ja ist äh die saga stream hatten wir ja hier schon mehrfach dargestellt,
und thomas thomas launiger hat ja eigentlich von anfang an ganz klar die position vertreten das was die telekom dort anbietet in deutschland mit diesem stream on paket,
verstößt gegen die ausgehandelte auf eu-ebene ausgehandelte richtlinien bezüglich der netz neutralität.
Und es hat lange gedauert bis hier überhaupt irgendwas passiert hat dann.
Ja die netze adventure irgendwann mal gekommen hat gesagt ja okay vielleicht ist doch nicht so richtig und jetzt hat das einen juristischen weg angetreten.
Genau was hat die bundesnetzagentur bemängelt genauso wie thomas sonniger und kunden von stream on erstens,
die drosselten bestimmter ipc verkehre in den günstigeren tarifen,
das ist also stream stream ist wenn ich das richtig verstehe eine zu buchbar option in wahrscheinlich allen oder so gut wie allen telekom tarifen die man heute noch bekommen kann und,
bei den,
niedriger be preisen tarifen wenn man dann das stream on aktiviert dann sorgt das dafür dass die bandbreite mit der man hier unten streamen kann im videobereich nur noch eine.
Schlechte qualität ermöglicht also hardy oder geht da nicht durch und das wird.
Es sei denn du bist halt ein partner der telekom und.
Nee dann eben nicht
dann eben nicht das ist ja genau der punkt es wird wenn du in den pilot tarifen bist was weiß ich magenta und du sagst stream und sagen die okay du kriegst aber wir drosselten,
wir drosselten die die bandbreite für video übertragungen und dadurch dass die bandbreite gedrosselt wird,
findet diese adaptive bandbreite,
und das heißt die sagen ja geiles alte und so ne frei volumen hast du nicht gesehen hier sind deine
fünfhundertvierzig p videos oder sowas oder was auch immer da irgendwie gerade durchgeschoben wird dvd qualität haben sie ja beworben ob die eigentlich auch bei bei dem audio dann sagen so in kassetten qualität,
in vhs qualität video und in in mc qualität audio ist doch super,
also diese drosselten wird kritisiert.
Interessanterweise wird nicht kritisiert was die eigentlich fundamentale.
Kritik wäre nämlich dass es überhaupt ein seo rating ist das ist ja das was ich grundsätzlich nicht gut finde,
weil es eben diese darin besteht ja die die ware ungleichbehandlung aber okay damit haben sie keine probleme.
Marcel finde ich gut und,
dass es beim roaming nicht funktioniert denn wenn du beim roaming wenn du nämlich jetzt mit deinem stream und tarif sagen wir mal nach holland fährst
und sagt ach nordsee gucken wir mal ein bisschen netflix in dvd qualität oder so dann,
geht das nicht denn das stream inklusiv unendlich volumen gilt,
nicht gilt nur in deutschland und das sehen sie als einen verstoß gegen die.
Gegen diese roaming deregulierung und in beiden bereichen,
hat die bundesnetzagentur auflagen gemacht die telekom hat geklagt also die bundesnetzagentur sagt diese draußen ist ein verstoß gegen die netz,
neutralität und weil es auf deutschland begrenzt ist ein verstoß gegen die eu roaming regeln dann hat die.
Bundesnetzagentur da eine anordnung erlassen dagegen hat die telekom geklagt und das verwaltungsgericht köln hat jetzt einen eilantrag der telekom gegen die anordnung der bundesnetzagentur abgewiesen,
das heißt die bundesnetzagentur hat recht bekommen damit hat die telekom ihre rechtsmittel in diesem all verfahren ausgeschöpft das hauptsache verfahren läuft aber weiter aber weil das ein verfahren
weil es einfach ausgeschöpft ist kann die telekom jetzt nicht warten.
Bis es im hauptsache verfahren eine entscheidung gibt und wird jetzt eben diese stream on,
irgendwie ändern müssen gemäß den anweisungen der bundesnetzagentur und die telekom sagt
geht davon aus dass sie im hauptsache verfahren gewinnen wird und dann hat ein sprecher der telekom gesagt wir werden jetzt prüfen wie wir mit dem urteil umgehen wir erwarten dass die bundesnetzagentur durch eine angemessene umsetzungs frisst die nun erforderlichen anpassungen ermöglicht,
streamen wird weiter angeboten und auch kostenlos bleiben
und der netzbetreiber will weiter kämpfen wir sind von der rechtmäßigkeit von stream on weiterhin überzeugt und werden auch zukünftig alle rechtlichen möglichkeiten ausschöpfen.
Zur klarstellung weil es wird es gerade vorgelesen hat ein bisschen verwirrend ist also dieser ein antrag der abgelehnt wurde das war im letzten november.
Vom verwaltungsgericht köln jetzt hat das oberverwaltungsgericht.
Das wiederum bestätigt.
Nordrhein-westfalen das bestätigt und damit muss die telekom jetzt aktiv werden und in irgendeiner form eine änderung,
herbeiführen ob diese änderung dann wirklich sofort auch wieder diesen anforderungen genügt steht auf dem anderen blatt auf jeden fall ist der ball jetzt erstmal zurück gespielt worden.
Was sich bärenstark finde ist dieser satz wir erwarten dass die bundesnetzagentur durch eine angemessene umsetzung frisst die nun erforderlichen anpassungen ermöglicht weil.
Dieser rechtsstreit der zieht sich seit über einem jahr hin die bundesnetzagentur hat gesagt pass auf es gibt gesetze in diesem land es gibt eu richtlinien.
Da muss sich daran halten sie bekommen hat gesagt nein nein da klage ich verloren,
oberlandesgericht nochmal verloren und jetzt hast du ja jetzt brauchen wir natürlich zeit
wir erwarten natürlich jetzt von der bundesnetzagentur dass sie uns zeit gibt uns an das gesetz und ihre anweisung von letzten jahr zu halten das ist schon stark ne ich meine da gibt's natürlich zwei.
Blicke drauf wenn du ernsthaft davon überzeugt bist dass das das das du das darfst obwohl ihr wie der rest der welt eindeutig klar sagt nein,
steht da.
Dann stellt sich natürlich schon die.
Also natürlich könntest du sagen also eine angemessene umsetzung frisst das finde ich geil eigentlich das werde ich bei meinen richtigen auseinandersetzung dann demnächst auch einfach sagen so ne also ja okay
gut wir haben jetzt hier ich habe jetzt zwei jahre prozess hinter mir hab verloren aber ich erwarte natürlich jetzt schon eine angemessene umsetzung frist bis ich die strafe bezahlen muss oder mich an das gesetz halten muss weil war ja vorher nicht klar wie das gesetz lautet
bevor bevor wir hier also da da,
nur weil sie weil sie uns vor einem jahr eine anweisung geschickt haben.
Wir dagegen geklagt haben heißt es ja nicht dass wir dass wir jetzt plötzlich uns daran halten müssen da muss er schon noch eine angemessene umsetzungs frist kommen das finde ich interessant.
Ja schauen wir mal was eine angemessene umsetzung frisst jetzt sein könnte der telekom schwebt bestimmt sowas vor wie nächstes jahr oder so.
Na ja die werden die denen die sehen natürlich die angemessene umsetzungs frisst natürlich brauchen wir eine angemessene umsetzungs frisst die haben ja im moment auch,
einen vertrag oder wahrscheinlich sehr viele verträge mit ihren kundinnen und kunden die diese stream als aspekt da drin haben das heißt im
würden sie das jetzt abschalten wer nach meiner nach meinem gerechtigkeit verständnis ich sag schon gar nicht mehr rechtsverständnis nach meinem gerechtigkeit verständnis hätten dann die kundinnen und kunden ein sonderkündigungsrecht na wenn du sagst es gibt hier stream online die sagen ach nee
gibt es gar nicht mehr sorry ist natürlich klar dass sie da das ist nicht einfach abschalten.
Ja die frage ist was jetzt eigentlich überhaupt
bieten können also ich meine wenn sie in irgendeiner form diesen vorteil aufrecht erhalten wollen und die auslosung und das roaming sind das kernproblem könnte man natürlich sagen ja okay dann lassen wir halt einfach die ausstellung sein,
womit wahrscheinlich das argument für viele der teuren verträge schnell wegfallen dürfte und das ist mit den anbietern ja glaube ich ziemlich egal denen ist ja sozusagen nur wichtig dass ihr überhaupt.
Da sind sozusagen dass sie erreichbar sind wenn diese limitierung wegfallen es ist glaube ich den vertrag kunden an der stelle wenn er nicht nur irgendwelche zahlungen mit verbunden sind also was ich mich erinnern kann wann das nur so.
Clemens wie man,
die sich ab daten liefern sie müssen sozusagen am laufenden meter so ein reporting mechanismus.
Muss welche wie das kostenlos gebucht werden muss und so weiter.
Genauso das heißt sie können im extremfall einfach die ausstellung sein lassen und das roaming da wird's natürlich gerne als sportlich weil sie natürlich für roaming andere kosten haben in abhängigkeit mit den,
verträgen den sie mit den anderen provider in europa haben,
ja das heißt wenn sie das dann quasi aufmachen dann müssten sie deutlich höhere,
unter umstände weiß ich nicht so ganz genau wie der markt da gerade funktioniert und wie die realen kosten sind die dürften auch gesunken sein,
müssen sie in kauf nehmen oder sie müssten dann halt entsprechend die angebote an ihre user.
Na die ja quasi aber nun mal genau das gebucht haben deswegen und sich im zweifelsfall deswegen auch für ein telekom vertrag
entschieden haben und das dürfte noch der schwierigere weg werden also kann durchaus teuer werden wenn sie einfach roaming aufmachen müssen und.
Oslo quasi,
aufgeben müssen was ja dann wiederum für die kunden die möglichkeit bieten würde sich auf einen günstigeren tarif runter zu klagen.
Sie haben außerdem also nur um so zu zeigen um so ein bisschen zu unterstreichen wie völlig in ordnung sie das finden ne haben sie vor kurzem noch die neue stream on social chat,
veröffentlicht ja neue tarife option soziale medien und messenger mobil nutzen ohne an das datenvolumen zu denken.
Musik kennen wir video und musik klären wir auch und,
wo er dann irgendwie maximale qualität bekommt das gibt's aber erst ab den m tarifen.
Und dann gibt's stream gaming deutschlandweit mobil online spielen ohne anders datenvolumen zu denken dann kannst du sofort spielen also die weiten das immer mehr,
aus und zu und ja das ergebnis wenn diese entfernt diese entwicklung.
Sinnvoll weitergeht dann ist natürlich irgendwann das ergebnis das,
eine eine flatrate für alle da steht die möchten das natürlich so lange wie möglich heraus zögern und wenn du,
jetzt überlegst du also mobilfunk betreiber blicken da natürlich quasi drauf als
naja es haben doch alle es kriegen ja alle interesting auch alle ihre dienste wir schaffen wir schaffen nur preis differenzierung damit die leute sich mehr leisten können auch mehr bezahlen ne also sie sehen ja quasi so eine,
sozialverträgliche bereits gedanken dahinter ne so,
ach du hast nicht so viel geld dann kommen da kriegst du hier schon mal surf und hast du alles nicht gesehen damit du am,
am netflix teilnehmen kannst und darüber füttern kannst und dann musst du nicht soviel bezahlen und wer mehr kann der kriegt das dann halt irgendwie,
der kann halt mehr bezahlen so so so stellen die so verargumentieren die natürlich diese diese tarife die brauchen ja preis differenzierung um eben,
leute die mehr nutzen vom netz haben auch irgendwie mehr bezahlen zu lassen das ist so ein bisschen der der gedanke gleichermaßen entwickelt sich das natürlich jetzt weiter jetzt kommen die mit fünf g netz deutsche telekom hat ja gerade irgendwo schon mal eine einzelne funkmasten angemacht.
Wo sie dann das nächste differenzierung merkmal wieder haben ne wo sie sagen werden achso ja du hast dann irgendwann ich glaube die rechnen sie mit einer zukunft von ok in paar jahren,
ist alles gefallen dann gibt's halt einfach viel geflattert für ein basis preis und dann ist das nächste preis differenzierung merkmal halt wieder fünf g.
Und in den ganzen fünf g netzen mit cloud und was er sich da alles ausgedacht haben claudia das ist der neueste.
Deutschland ist jetzt schon eine einzige cloud.
Ich habe da schon jetzt klappt ja ja ja stimmt.
Ich bin ja jetzt gerade an diesem wochenende aus barcelona wieder zurückgekommen und ich habe sofort zum des tages geschafft in.
Im tagesspiegel.
Ja die wählen immer einen tweet des tages ja und.
Was war der tipp des tages.
Ich schreib einfach nur zurück in berlin war eine schöne zeit in barcelona aber es gibt da einfach zugute rat infrastruktur internet überall saubere straßen das hält ja kein mensch aus.
Mir ist das ja aufgefallen jetzt kann man gleich gut erzählt du hast ja dann aus deutschland angerufen und ich merke sofort an der scheiß sprach qualität dass du nicht mehr in spanien bist das ist wirklich es ist wirklich so ja.
Ich stand auf ich stand auf einem autobahn park platz und es gab nur.
Ja was sei froh.
Sei froh ich stand da ich wollte mein scheiß luftdruck irgendwie checken wollten nachschlagen was brauche ich denn jetzt hier für den druck nee nein deutschland so nein.
Es war wieder so typisch.
Dann halt doch das messgerät an den anderen reifen da siehst du doch wie viel luftdruck.
Die anhänger und.
Also da steht drauf oben drüber bei den anhängern.
In abhängigkeit von der beladung blablabla ich wollte mich einfach versichern dachte mal benutzt man das internet wofür ist da ist ich wollte ja noch nicht mal netflix gucken ich wollte einfach nur eine fucking hate im seite laden nicht.
Und bevor ihr euch jetzt sorgt dass die dass die sprache qualität schlecht war,
wegen des lärm es nein sie ist schlecht je nachdem welche mobilfunk technologie zum einsatz kommt das was zwei geh an sprach qualität ermöglicht ist ich frag ich freue mich ernsthaft wie wir damals damit telefoniert haben,
ich höre heute also wenn ich in zwei habe ne ich verstehe nicht ich schreibe dann auch wieder weißt du wieso.
Hallo hallo tim tim hallo hörst du mich wo bist du bist du in deutschland.
Hallo fürchterlich.
Geh doch nochmal kurz über die grenze damit ich dich hören kann.
Du musst entlang begrenze warte du bist einfach entlang der ost krätze vorsichtig ne wenn du von vom süden reinkommst dann fährst du schön an der grenze lang außen rum.
Aber es ist doch eh noch einiges zu optimieren weil ich musste meine rückrunde natürlich auch so legen das war okay zugegebenermaßen auch tatsächlich der kürzeste weg aber ich hätte im prinzip auch noch meinen weg über die schweiz machen können nur.
Oh da hättest du nochmal richtig der jetzt nochmal so einen richtigen bitch schub bekommen.
Nicht nur schub der dich auch so.
Bald schub.
Also so ein euro schub von meinem konto wegbekommen war ich wahrscheinlich allein durch einmal durchfahren nicht einmal das handy in die hand nehmen schon mal wieder fünfzig euro bezahlt hätte.
Ach so du hast ja so ein das ja auch so ein.
Na ich hab halt es halt nicht eu roaming da sondern du musst halt einen vertrag nein es bei dir nicht eu roaming,
nein es ist nicht weil es ja nicht eu roaming ist sondern es ist
ein schweiz roaming deines vertrages was explizit die schweiz mit inkludiert weil das für dich praktisch ist weil du wahrscheinlich öfter bis als in der schweiz bis als ich
aber ich fahre halt immer nur durch und bin von zwei stunden fünfzig euro zu bezahlen für nichts und das war's.
Lieber kunde sie nutzen ohne weitere kosten innerhalb der eu island lichtenstein norwegen und der schweiz ihren tarif für telefonie sms und internet.
Ja es handelt sich trotzdem.
Sogar der notruf ist kostenlos.
Es ist trotzdem nicht eu.
Länder gruppe eins eben.
Ja was ein telekom.
Erwischt aber die schlechte tonqualität lag an dir.
Ich sag ja nur es ist noch einiges zu verbessern auch wenn wir fortschritte gehabt haben und jetzt.
Die empfangsgeräte sind schon mal ganz gut rest kann man noch was machen.
Was war eigentlich gerade das thema.
Stream du wolltest youtube gucken aufm offen autobahnraststätte.
Rastet.
Ach so jetzt wisst ihr natürlich jetzt hätte ich jetzt eine kurze meldung vorweg genommen aber das ist natürlich wichtig anzuerkennen klimawandel ist ein thema.
Und.
Es wird sich jetzt nach und nach damit auseinander genommen man hat uns jetzt schon den spaß am fliegen genommen jetzt wenn man uns auch noch viel anderen spaß nehmen denn es wurde untersucht wieviel
c o zwei produziert wird durch online pornos und es ist ungefähr so viel wie rumänien,
also die der online porno konsum der welt,
so viel co zwei frei wie rumänien.
Das heißt wir müssen natürlich jetzt rumänien abschalten weil wir uns das einfach nicht mehr leisten können.
Also jetzt in deutschland der porno.
Nein der globale der globale zu zwei ausstoß durch online pornographie weltweit hatte geschätzt den gleichen kohlenstoffdioxid zieht ausstoß wie der das unterhalten des landes rumänien.
So das ist von einer studie von einem namens der shift projekt die sich also mit der klimakrise auseinander setzen und sagen der ansatz szene die anzahl auf online,
video und ich finde diese.
Aus vielen verschiedenen gründen sehr interessant vor allem weil sie regelmäßig zu ganz anderen ergebnissen kommen als vielleicht jetzt,
in unkenntnis intuitiv erwartet würde.
Na setze jetzt nicht gedacht dass das das so viel zwei.
Ich freue mich auf wie sie zu diesem ergebnis gekommen sind dass ich für diese ganzen co zwei verbrauchst dinger meine was was ziehen sie denn da jetzt bitte heran.
Na ja du kannst ja also das kannst du ja schon relativ einfach nähern was die was der betrieb von info internet,
infrastruktur kostet,
was der betrieb an diesen daten centern kostet was die computer am anderen ende kosten was du irgendwie mehr luft weg atmest,
während du diesen film gucken und das kann man ja alles ernährungsweise ausrechnen.
Und dann kannst du natürlich gucken okay wofür wird dieses gesamte internet giraffe genutzt und dann stellst du halt fest aha,
vierunddreißig prozent netflix siebenundzwanzig prozent porno und youporn einundzwanzig prozent youtube achtzehn prozent tiktok.
Und netflix und co sind demnach ungefähr so viel co zwei ausstoß wie belgien online pornos wie rumänien.
Insgesamt liegt online streaming auf dem niveau von spanien.
Das war's schon mal in rumänien na dann können wir darauf verzichten ich war auch noch nicht da wir drehen das jetzt einfach mal ab.
Auf jeden fall liegt rumänien im glasfaserausbau vor deutschland hat wird das gut das war aber nur eine kurze meldung.
Es sei denn du möchtest da noch länger darauf eingehen du hast jetzt zweifel.
Ich habe generell zweifel weil ich schon so viele gerade im elektromobil bereich gab so viele studien die da in den letzten jahren rauskommen und immer wieder zitiert werden die bei genauer im hinblick den
komplett auf die nase gefallen sind und wenn wir jetzt irgendwelche wissenschaftler mit solchen vergleichen daher kommt solchen studie mit ja hier porno.
Ne ich meine bessere methode die schlagzeilen zu kommen gibt's halt auch kaum.
Also ich möchte nur sagen ich glaube dass es.
Die wissenschaftler wollen uns unsere online pornos wegnehmen das ist doch das ist doch die eigentliche botschaft die dahinter.
Nein da stand ja nicht zur debatte die.
Da müssen einfach mal die ausgaben gekürzt werden diesen bereich.
Die frage ist ob wir uns rumänien weiter leisten können oder.
Wie viel wie cdu zwei verbrauchen eigentlich die wissenschaftler beim erstellen dieser studien wieviel rumäniens wir malta s.
Das problem ist ich finde es wirklich ich finde dieses thema wirklich interessant vor allem so wenn man den jetzt mal gegenüber setzt ich glaube dass das schlimmste das allerschlimmste was du gegen das klima tun kannst.
Ist ein kind kriegen.
Weil das natürlich ein kabeln food print hat auf seine lebenszeit egal was es tut der größer ist als alles andere insofern würde ich mir überlegen,
ob man nicht sagen komm lieber pornos gucken ja vielleicht ist das am ende doch besser für das klima.
Ja wie viel kinder müsste man einsparen damit wir alle weiter beruhigt online pornos gucken können.
Ich habe schon mal eins gespart für euch wichser.
Okay nächst.
So apropos wichser da sind wir auch schon beim nächsten thema.
Wir haben ja vor einiger zeit in deutschland den verfassungsschutz chef hans-georg maaßen,
endlich freigestellt das problem was wir jetzt haben ist mit seiner ganzen freizeit versucht er auch etwas anzufangen kleinere kapitulation seiner karriere.
Es war eigentlich nach der nsu affäre ja als die als ein paar nazi terroristen in deutschland,
entdeckt wurden nachdem wir ungefähr über weit länger als ein jahrzehnt den hinterbliebenen ihrer opfer gesagt haben eure,
familienangehörigen waren in wirklichkeit klaren kriminelle deswegen wurden die erschossen und nicht von irgendwelchen irren nazi mördern und der bundesverband das wurde es am für verfassungsschutz eigentlich nur so bei in anbetracht der nachrichten sagte so
schröder schröder schröder und dann ein neuer mann an die spitze musste eingesetzt damals von innenminister hans,
peter friedrich erinnerst du dich noch den haben wir danach nochmal kurz in die landwirtschaft geschickt und inzwischen ist er glaube ich auch nur noch irgendwie so ein.
Ja ungefähr auf dem gleichen niveau von maaßen in so einem irgend so ein,
plumper schreihals in der csu wurde da eigentlich als reformer hin geholt was,
da an reformen stattgefunden hat kann man eigentlich jetzt im nachhinein nicht feststellen er hat eine doktorarbeit geschrieben die mehrere,
verschwörungstheorien hatte und sich schon mit zuwanderung auseinander setzte,
und irgendwie so begriffe enthält wie unkontrollierte massenzuwanderung und asyl tourismus also da hat sich schon abgezeichnet des geistes kind er ist auch unvergessen ist als er noch referat innenministerium war.
Und zweitausendzwei ein rechtsgutachten darüber schrieb sie denn mit dem murat nass umzugehen sei der in,
montana mobile festgehalten wurde von amerikanern.
Und ob sich denn der die die deutsche regierung einsetzen muss für diesen menschen als sein staatsbürger oder der irgendwie damit etwas zu tun hat und maaßen sagte dann
nein,
mit denen müssen wir uns nicht auseinander setzen weil sein aufenthaltsrecht ist ja verfallen weil der sechs monate nicht in deutschland war und deswegen müssen wir uns auch nicht mehr für diese menschen einsetzen das bekannte warum der sechs monate nicht in deutschland war ist,
weil die den guantanamo festgehalten haben ja also so hat maaßen schon zweitausendzwei argumentiert,
für unsere hörerinnen und hörer sicherlich auch unvergessen die landesverrat affäre die jetzt ungefähr vier jahre her ist weil sie war kurz vor dem camp zweitausendfünfzehn,
wo gegen andere meister und markus becker wegen,
landesverrat es ermittelt werden sollte was sich letztendlich dann auf
nach einigen wochen durch intervention in luft auflöst wir erinnern uns an die entlassung des generalbundesanwalt des herrn range,
durch maß heiko maas zeug man wenn man über maß und mars,
da ist auch irgendwann das maßvoll da nochmal einen kleinen calauer unterzubringen.
Also dieser typ den wir dann irgendwann endlich losgeworden sind weil er sich.
Also als als leiter des bundes bundesamtes für verfassungsschutz einfach vollständig qualifiziert disqualifiziert hat durch seine öffentlich geäußerten rechten verschwörungstheorien der hat sich jetzt auf twitter.
Über einen.
Eine äußerung oder einen artikel der bz aufgeregt der neuen zürcher zeitung.
Und hat dann irgendwie gesagt dieser dieser artikel.
Also die z sei für ihn so etwas wie west fernsehen wo ich mich.
Sogar auf frage was er was er damit,
meint ich glaube der der kontext ist hier in der city eigentlich immer ein relativ liberales und intellektuelles blatt war da wird gerade so eine.
Findet gerade eigentlich ein ein rechtsruck statt der da der laden wird jetzt von anderen leuten geführt da sind viele entlassen worden und müssen jetzt irgendwie auch so eine
rechte
seiner scharf rechte positionen vertreten und er bezeichnet quasi diese zeitung die jetzt quasi ein drei nach rechts bekommt als west fernsehen weil er ja hier ne die historische rolle von west fernsehen,
die nachhinein,
gesagt wird ist ja du hast irgendwie in der ddr gesessen du hattest keinen zugang zu ungefilterten informationen deswegen hattest du
in in der nähe der der grenze der innerdeutschen grenze konntest du eben heimlich west fernsehen gucken was natürlich auch absichtlich weit in dein land hinein gestrahlt wurde war höchst verboten und da war eben da war dann eben die andere wahrheit zu sehen ne die ungeschminkte wahrheit und so so bezeichnet er jetzt hier diese
diese z als als west fernsehen und zitierte dann noch.
Was er was er damit meint es aber nicht tagesschau sein er z d f magazin falls ihr das noch was sagen.
Da sagt mir tatsächlich nichts.
Magazin ist so gemein hin die west antwort auf den schwarzen kanal im osten gewesen als schwarzer kanal war ja sozusagen so diese,
propaganda kommentar sendung wo die ganze zeit der wissen in den untergrund geredet wurde.
Und gerhard löwe thal hat das c f magazin halt für den westen übernommen also das war dann sozusagen auch die ganze zeit so der osten ist schlecht und riecht nach logo unerträglich und.
Das meint er wahrscheinlich mit.
Okay also west fernsehen ist für ihn ist für ihn auf jeden fall ein.
Thema.
Es gab dann noch eine weiteren ein weiteres thema was jetzt die ganze zeit die,
in den letzten wochen die medien beschäftigt hat und das war die auseinandersetzung zwischen carola rakete,
der kapitän der sea-watch drei und dem italienischen,
dusche nee kapitalen oder wie der sich nennt ne,
salvini dem innenminister der da auch nach sag ich mal nach trump schon lehrbuch dort sehr,
straffe parolen und hetze verbreitet ihr habt das thema sicherlich verfolgt da gab es dann einen.
Panorama bericht
als panorama die mit an bord waren und quasi das was dort vorgefallen ist,
als journalistinnen an bord der sea-watch mitgefilmt haben und darüber ein bericht,
veröffentlicht haben ja der also dann zeigt okay was war da los auf dem,
kann ne die hatten da ja was war das dreiundvierzig menschen,
gerettet die sie auf diesem boot jetzt versorgt haben mussten mit denen an land am ende entscheidet sich carola im,
in einer situation wo sie keinen ausweg mehr weiße sagt ich fahre jetzt in diesem hafen ein funk das durch sagt ich werde das jetzt tun nachdem sie da wochenlang irgendwie vorher umgang haben wird dann noch von den.
Italienischen kräften daran gehindert die auf koalitions kors zu dem schiff gehen es gibt es kommt zu einer nicht kollision aber zu einem rums und das alles hat panorama eben von aus dem schiff
mitgenommen und dieser bericht zeigt natürlich ein etwas anderes bild als das was irgendwie der,
der dusche und einige rechte medien eben verbreiten dass das irgendwie eine schlepper bande ist letztendlich diese
menschen die dort seit jahren mehr leben menschenleben retten und maaßen verlinkt dazu den kommentar eine veröffentlichung die unter dem namen journalistin watch
bekannt geworden ist.
Und die dann irgendwie so ein artikel schreibt wie racket und die sea-watch rakete und die sea-watch drei alles nur ein fernsehspiel für ard und,
panorama und hans-georg maaßen verbreitet diesen link von seinem twitteraccount und sagt sollte dieser bericht zutreffen ist panorama jedenfalls,
kein west fernsehen also west fernsehen interessant ist für ihn wichtig ne das ist da ist er.
Die freiheit.
Der ist halt auch ernsthaft in dieser zeit packen geblieben der typ ne und.
Das ist natürlich auch verschiedene art und weise bemerkenswert weil dieses journalisten watch ist irgendwie so eine.
Eine seite von irgendwelchen afd nahen die also sich größtenteils mit.
Ja mit also die quasi den journalisten zeigt ja schon so diesen nimbus der des ausruf s lügenpresse ne wo also in einem blog sehr viele hetze und fake news verbreitet werden unter der idee,
es sei irgendwie von der die weltverschwörung der der,
wer auch immer gerade wieder lügen erzählt korrektiv behandelt die die veröffentlichung dieses blogs sehr regelmäßig.
In seiner in seinem faktencheck a und kommt dann,
sehr häufig zu dem ergebnis und belegt falsch und war völlig falsch größtenteils falsch und so weiter gleichzeitig wird das ding irgendwie shady finanziert und ja,
ist also wirklich also das ist ernsthaft halt das ist halt so ist halt einfach.
Dass kein west fernsehen das ist das ist auch kein ost fernsehen das einfach nur scheiße.
Russland russland fertig.
Ne die sind finanziert von da gab es auch eine wunderschöne recherche von korrektiv ähm die heißen die die das ding finanzieren das ist in so einem mittel ist geschichte.
Das mittel ist form eine islam feindliche thinktank der,
den der diesen blog journalisten rutsch halt finanziert ansonsten sind sie über spenden und werbung finanziert der mitbegründer des blogs war,
oder der gründer des blogs war mitgründer der partei die freiheit eine rechtsradikale partei die vom bayerischen verfassungsschutz beobachtet wurde also so die schiene ne.
Und,
du fragst dich ernsthaft was was da los ist dass unser ehemaliger verfassungsschutz schützer also ich endlich in in diese.
In diesem bereich ein einsetzt und da hat also das wird ein nur angst und bange ne wenn der den laden jetzt die letzten jahre geführt hat und was der.
Für verschwörungstheorien jetzt in die welt setzen kann und alle sagen ja der der der mann vom verfassungsschutz der hat schon immer gewusst ne der wurde
geschafft weil er die wahrheit gesagt hat und so und jetzt haben wir damals schon befürchtet als wir uns ganz kurz gefreut haben ihn los zu sein und ja,
so ist es auch nicht einen großartigen kommentar von markus reuter bei netzwerk der zum lesen sehr empfohlen ist der enthemmt dermaßen zeigt wie gefährlich der verfassungsschutz ist,
das problem wenn so jemand über jahre chef eines geheimdienste sein konnte dann ist der verfassungsschutz noch gefährlicher für die demokratie
als wir alle immer dachten und da hat er natürlich recht dass es wirklich nicht mehr unbedingt witzig,
was da passiert money code in dem in dem artikel ist übrigens maaßen ist der geheimdienst gewordene sarrazin der christdemokraten.
Der motto sack unter den schlapp wüten eine erika steinbach mit nickel brille großartig also danke für diesen schönen
kommentar und der vielleicht noch ein bisschen hilft hier darüber zu lachen aber das sind das zu die
ich will jetzt nicht immer wiederholen dass wir in logbuch netz politik einfach die letztendlich behandeln dass die befürchtungen die wir vor zehn zwanzig jahren oder dreißig jahren auch hatten alle wahr werden aber.
Das ist halt so.
Ja das ist ja auch gerade eine kultur des fc,
stand ja,
von anfang an der widerstand gegen so ideen der total überwachung aller aller allerersten texten formuliert worden und zahlreiche kongresse immer wieder durch integriert wurden
stand auch immer ein argument ganz vorne nämlich.
Lass uns keine infrastruktur und keine systeme und gesetze schaffen die es im falle eines,
der übernahme nicht mehr demokratie basiert a kräfte erlauben würden sofort das ganze so zu nutzen wie es teilweise eben,
nazis auch getan haben.
Klassischen beispiele so die katalonische erfassung aller juden in deutschland maschinell verarbeitung mit den ersten maschinen und so weiter das wurde sozusagen sofort genutzt und auch in diesem ganzen diskurs
die wir jetzt in den letzten monaten hatten mit was so nazis so machen
ja die erstellen halt listen teilweise sagt ja auch die afd schon ganz klar wenn wir erstmal an der macht sind dann gehen wir hier
dem journalismus an die backe und jeden der sich irgendwie halbwegs kritisch geäußert hat wenn man irgendwie da
als auswischen oder noch stärker verfolgen und das ist genau das wovon wir immer gesprochen haben.
Ich weiß auch dass wir in der öffentlichen reaktion auf dieser argumentation hin immer so ein bisschen belächelt worden mit ja aber nazizeit ist doch jetzt vorbei,
ja das ist,
muss man sich auch klar machen dass das damals auch ein sehr starkes gefühl war in dieser gesellschaft es geht jetzt langsam verloren gott sei dank aber so dieses so ja nee nazizeit sehr vorbei und geht
gut so soll es bleiben kanzler kohl führt uns nach europa alles prima alles freunde um uns herum was kann schon passieren,
und dass das eben alles auf ziemlich dünn eis
gebaut sein kann bisweilen zeigt uns der auch dieser politische klimawandel ja also das was mal irgendwie wie 'ne feste eis decke aussah so langsam vor sich hin taut man muss nur nach großbritannien schauen land was.
Sich jetzt sozusagen,
fünfzig sechzig jahre daran braucht hat wie geil sie doch mal die nazis abgeliefert haben die sich jetzt quasi mit ihrem ganzen brexit prozesse im prinzip selben pappnasen in die erste reihe stellen diese,
und wenn wir halt nicht aufpassen treten uns die vögel halt hier auch ein meine geh mal davon aus dass es jetzt nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich ist dass in den ländern tatsächlich eine afd regierung möglich ist ja ist ja nicht
wird passieren aber es zumindest jetzt nicht mehr so komplett absurd der gedanke.
Was machen sie denn dann mit dem verfassungsschutz dem landesamt für verfassungsschutz als erstes welche welche maßnahmen ergreifen die denn
im rahmen der neuen polizei gesetzgebung ach man kann jetzt auch gefährder einfach so festnehmen ohne dass irgendwie ein gericht da ein verhaftung beschluss fällen muss wie praktisch,
da fallen uns einige gefährder ein da haben wir übrigens auch eine liste schon.
So und das werden wir sehen,
und das kein schöner gedanke und wenn ich mir anschaue wie hasen physisch immer noch auf sowas wie diesen mord an lübke reagiert wird also freue mich halt auch wirklich so was bitte,
die cdu überhaupt noch in wallung wenn noch nicht mal ausreicht dass die leute irgendwie dass ihre eigenen leute auf offener straße exportiert werden.
Ist das ist uns aber da das ist tatsächlich der der der völlige,
das zeigt die beängstigend das ist ja weil du selbst von diesen cdu,
leuten hättest erwarten müssen dass sie vielleicht noch protestieren wenn einer von ihnen erschossen wird und.
Du kannst so richtig merken so doof sind die ja auch nicht dass sie dass sie das denn nicht klar wird oh scheiße das hätte auch ich sein können und genau das
wollen sie natürlich vermeiden
genau da sagen wir also ach ok hier ich muss nochmal kurz im verkehrsausschuss mich über irgendwelche elektroroller aufregen oder so oder vielleicht habe ich ja auch grade noch ein anderes thema über das ich twittern kann hauptsache,
ich bin jetzt hier nicht der nächste lücke reicht ja wenn wir zensur oder zwei punkt null haben brauchen wir nicht noch lücke zwei punkt null.
Und das ist schon echt krass weil das ist das ist das wovor wovor du immer angst haben muss oder wovor was du immer befürchten muss dass irgendwann nämlich die die nazis so viel angst geschürt haben.
Und so stark in den eigenen reihen vertreten sind.
Und so stark in den eigenen reihen vertreten sind dass sie die gefühlte mehrheit sind die ich glaube,
das sind jetzt auch theorie ne ich glaube nicht dass das in in nazi deutschland wirklich die mehrheit der menschen.
Gesagt hat oder eine eine eine große mehrheit der menschen gesagt hat das was hier passiert ist schon in ordnung das finden wir super so gedacht hat,
die haben sich nicht getraut das zu sagen wir feiern heute
irgendwie als national heldinnen so ein paar leute wie irgendwie weiße rose die man das eine oder andere flugblatt sich getraut haben zu verteilen und dafür sofort erschossen wurden.
Ja dass das also das oder stauffenberg der versucht hat den.
Der ganzen sache mit einem mit einem attentaten ende zubereiten auch nicht unbedingt einen zweifel über alle zweifel erhaben mensch aber,
das sind ja effektiv sehr sehr wenige widerstandsfähig formen die da überhaupt gezeigt wurden weil du halt auch sofort auf die fresse bekommen hast.
Und ich glaube das ist so ein bisschen das was mir am meisten sorgen macht dass die offenbar noch nicht einmal dass die jetzt schon schiss haben.
Also in brandenburg plakatiert die afd unter anderem so plakate wie winde zwei null und jetzt die wände vollenden ja,
also.
Generiert sich sozusagen auch wieder so als widerstand gegen den bösen staat und jetzt müsste man ja sozusagen nochmal hier eine revolution einleiten.
Mir bleibt nur zu sagen also mit wenn er das nicht zu tun einzige was dann kommt ist eine rolle rückwärts und da falls ihr ordentlich auf die fresse und wir dann gleich.
Wenn die cdu dann nicht mehr in der lage ist sich da quasi koalition zu verwerten dann muss man ihn halt leider halt auch die passenden mehrheit durch nicht wahl.
Nicht weil der cdu aber wir sind ja voll neutraler.
Das ist also dieses dieses neutral ne der kai grieche auch inzwischen ein ein kamm wenn ich irgendwelche leute im heutigen zeiten noch irgendwas von politischer neutralität,
reden höre die zu zu wahren sei ja nein ist sie nicht,
es nicht zu warm war sie haben wir gelernt haben in der schule schon gelernt aus gutem grund dass es dass es nicht darum geht politisch neutral zu sein sondern dass es darum geht politisch zu.
Sind wir versuchen mal zumindest zu sein.
Kommen wir zu etwas erhalten darin themen.
Hatten wir schon die gute nachricht der der ne die gute nachricht kommt noch ne hatten wir eine gute nachricht bleiben sie dran.
Wir bis zum ende durch hat wird auch eine gute nacht.
Eine gute nachricht.
Genau das hier ist sicherlich jetzt keine große nachricht aber es trotzdem mal wieder so ein schöner schönes zeit dokument ist für falls von lieb gewonnenen tradition,
der vfb stuttgart im ging es nicht so gut geht es auch immer noch nicht so gut viel stress im verein dann mussten sie auch noch gegen union verlieren beziehungsweise.
Besiegelt bekommen sorry ähm und jetzt stand eine.
Mitgliederversammlung an die stattfand da im stadion und,
die war ohnehin schon ziemlich erhitzt es ging nämlich um nicht weniger als eine mögliche abwahl es doch extrem unbeliebtesten herrn dietrich dem,
vorsitzenden des vereins da ist er erst seit zwei jahren und so richtig gut es ist irgendwie alles nicht gelaufen in der zeit
und er hat sich auch warum man nicht unbedingt besonders durch volks näher oder vereins näher oder sowas ausgezeichnet egal dass ich auch gar nicht weiter interpretieren auf jeden fall stand es eben an dort wichtige entscheidungen zu fällen,
und was macht man wenn wichtige entscheidungen gefällt werden sollen wo es wirklich auf jede stimme ankommt na klar.
Annimmt computer dafür und so steht es nämlich mittlerweile auch in der satzung des vereins das eine abstimmung ja elektronisch zu erfolgen habe.
Und wenn man das.
Zu erfolgen habe.
Habe und wenn das nicht erfolgen solle dann könnte man da müsste man darüber auch nochmal abstimmen also elektronische.
Pfiffig ne.
Ja und die.
Technologie die dort zum einsatz kommt ist von einem berliner anbieter namens pudding.
Und funktioniert wohl so dass es da eine app gibt und es wird dann,
an dem jeweiligen veranstaltungsort ein diversifiziertes wlan für diesen voting vorgangs aufgesetzt wo man quasi entweder mit einer runtergeladen app sich da mit einem,
bei eintritt zur veranstaltung vergebenen sechsstelligen code quasi autorisiert darf das heißt man weiß halt mit,
mitglieds ausweis nach dass man stimmt berechtigt ist,
und wo man halt sonst sowieso eine rote karte oder sowas in die hand gedrückt bekommen kriegt man halt hier so einen sechsstelligen code nebst eines ausführlichen
dina vier zettel als der einem dann irgendwie versucht zu erklären wie denn das jetzt alles so funktioniert und welche komplizierten maßnahmen man denn einleiten muss so ne
und muss halt ins wlan reingehen,
schon mal sehr schön die formulierung hier um eine abstimmung teilnehmen zu können müssen sie sich im freien wlan vfb mv zwanzig neunzehn einwählen das wlan ist nicht verschlüsselt,
so schon mal gut ne aber es irgendwie alles mit total,
es ist elmar ist weil es nicht sicher ist naja und dann musst du da eine webseite aufrufen.
Die also quasi irgendwie lokal ausgeliefert wird und da gibt's dann diesen zug zugangscode ein.
Da habe ich noch überlegt ob die lokal ausgeliefert wird weil ich sofort gedacht habe was das sind um mein name kann ich dir nicht einfach mal kaufen und das lieber nicht lokal ausliefern.
Kann ich nicht sagen also darüber hab ich jetzt keine erkenntnisse also es ist irgendwie wie in.
Also die domain gibt es unter laufen auch laufen auch abstimmen drunter also ich ich bin mir nicht sicher ob du wirklich in diesem wlan sein muss kann sein dass sie.
Du also du musst es in diesem wlan sein ja genau also kannst du nicht irgendwie über alte sondern es war sozusagen separat und du musst halt diesen zugangscode,
eingeben wenn du nicht über ein eigenes smartphone verfügt so aus anderen gründen nicht darüber arbeiten willst dann wurde die auch so ein tablet in der hand gedrückt.
Es gibt ja nichts schöneres als als wahlen von einem antrag city weiß.
Genau ach du kannst dich elektronisch wählen hier ist ein elektronisches gerät.
Sie haben kein wahlzettel soll ich ihnen einen geben oh man.
Ja ja genau und so funktioniert das.
Ähm und da muss man auch diesen code angeben angeblich das hab ich jetzt noch nicht doppelt bestätigen können aber angeblich wird dieser code wohl.
In dem moment generiert und sei auch nur dann auf diesem gerät anwendbar ja wo ich mich dann halt auch wieder rum frage.
Haben sie den cookie gesetzt oder was soll das sein.
Hi kann ich dir nicht sicher sagen es gibt da irgendeine identifizierung ist ohnehin sehr schön wie sie einem ausführlich erklären dass diese ganze abstimmung ja total anonym ist ja,
nachdem du dich mit einem code der dir zugeteilt also der,
der code wird nicht dir zugeteilt wann du kriegst irgendwie einen der angeblich nicht mit deiner person identifizieren.
Das ist ja auch das ist ja tatsächlich so denkbar also was sie da beschreiben.
Ja trotzdem sagen sie dir das sehr schön wohl war diese formulierung,
ja also weder nicht verschlüsselt dann musste ich auf dieser website einlesen dann die eingesetzten tablets dem kiosk modus ne also alles voll sicher dann musst du diese.
Pin eingeben also muss zusätzlich noch eine pin eingeben auf diesem gerät.
Ja genau.
Mit dem hinweis nutzen sie eine zahlen kombination die sie sich gut merken können.
Dann musst du diese pin auch auf dieser website eingeben und das an dieser wahl vorgang danach ist der wahlzettel abgesehen und liegt wie so schön sagen sozusagen in der wahlurne.
Und jetzt kommt der geile hinweis bitte beachten sie das ladegerät ist auf sie als nutzer registriert und wird ihnen bei nicht rückgabe in rechnung gestellt ist aber alles voll anonym.
Also was sie da was wir da machen ich.
Die haben natürlich die sie können behaupten.
Das dadurch dass so also dadurch dass sie den den prozess du weißt nach dass du wahlberechtigt bist und bekommst dann diesen sechs stelligen code.
Der eine eine wahlberechtigt übung darstellt und das irgendwie auf papier stattfindet und dazwischen keine zuordnung stattfindet können sie tatsächlich.
Für geeignete werte von behaupten behaupten,
dass es jetzt anonym seine weil die die diese zu diese prüfung deiner wahl berechtigung findet anders statt als die zuweisungen dieses codes der kurs wird von mir aus aus irgendeiner urne genommen das heißt niemand weiß welchen code du hast
und dann wird unter dem code eine stimme hinterlegt und diese diese man weiß nur dass der code wahlberechtigt ist weiß aber nicht mit sicherheit,
dass er von dir ist du befindest dich aber jetzt nochmal in einem wlan.
Wo zum beispiel dein gerät am laufenden band schreit ich bin übrigens iphone von horst uwe ja und außerdem hast du interesse wenn du in dem.
Und es eins von diesen dreißig wähler als die ich normalerweise benutze irgendwie gerade zufällig hier.
Und was aber der was ich hier an diesem ganzen verfahren ne also die können das argument halten dass sie im zweifelsfall schwierigkeiten haben nachzuweisen wer von jeder einzelne person nachzuweisen wer was gewählt hat.
Glaube ich ihn auch.
Können sie das können sie mit dem verfahren durchaus mal.
Glaube ich ihn auch ich finde nur diese ganzen formulierungen und wie sich das ganze sozusagen ein präsentiert schon etwas bedenklich,
na ja am ende haben wir vielleicht gleich nochmal auf die.
Deswegen funktioniert nicht.
Naja das er hätte vielleicht funktioniert das problem ist nur dass diese viertausendfünfhundert anwesenden und stimmberechtigte personen nun alle dann zu irgendeinem zeitpunkt aufgeführt aufgefordert worden doch jetzt mal dieses wlan reinzugehen,
was
auch erst für viele erst in dem moment eine option war weil sie natürlich alle schon interesse daran hat irgendwie internet zu haben weil sie am zittern diskutieren und was weiß ich facebook lesen waren was man halt alles so macht nur wenn du in diesem
voting wlan bis gibt's halt nur voting und kein internet was wiederum dazu geführt hat dass natürlich alle nur auf zu ruft so jetzt hallo alle da rein,
in dieses netz reingegangen sind was natürlich für so netz an sich auch schon mal ein problem dass.
War aber alles noch viel schlimmer weil es dann irgendwie zur abstimmung kommen sollte.
Wie fällt irgendwie gar nichts ich bin mir immer noch nicht so ganz so sicher was die leute mit ihren mit ich kam nicht rein genau gemeint war ob sie schon nicht in das wlan reinkam oder ob sie in das wlan reinkam aber dann keine verbindung herstellen konnten,
ich vermute mal letzteres weil es gab dann berichte die sagten ja der vfb stuttgart wollte ein bisschen geld sparen hat deswegen irgendwie die ganze roter konfiguration des bilanz und wir selber übernommen,
was soll ich denn gut über die idee war und auch ausrufezeichen
unbestätigten information aber es gab vor irgendwie so eine atmen aussage oder
leute haben sich dann quasi mal angeschaut was denn überhaupt für adressen zugeteilt wurden und natürlich war das nur so ein pkv netz mit einem slash dreiundzwanzig netzwerk
und
während die advents jetzt schon laut lachen zur erklärung für alle anderen das legt sozusagen fest wieviel nutzbar adressen ist gibt und das sind dann halt so was wie.
Naja fünfhundert adressen.
Bei einem ich habe müsste ich jetzt nachrechnen weil hier steht was anderes.
Ich weiß aber ich hab's eben gerade nochmal.
Du hast nochmal neu okay alles klar.
Korrigiert weil das vierundzwanzig halter seit acht bitte zusagen übrig also jetzt halt zweihundert also abzüglich der null und eins eins einsatzzeit irgendwie zwei dreiundfünfzig und haushalt,
auf jeden fall nicht genug ja also sagen wir nur so ein so ein netzwerk anbietet und auch noch nicht mal genug adressen frei gibt das irgendwie viertausendfünfhundert leute teilnehmer können dann ist halt alles durch was ist also letzten endes passiert diese veranstaltung.
Musste am ende abgebrochen werden es kam zu keiner abstimmung weil,
wie es so schön hieß das wlan nicht funktioniert hat gab natürlich ein riesen geschrei der präsident der vielleicht diese abstimmung gerade noch so überlebt hätte musst du jetzt einen tag später zurücktreten gab so schöne formulierung wie er ist über das w-lan kabel gestürzt.
Weil natürlich der verein auch keinerlei plan b am start hatte das haben sie wohl irgendwie ja vorher auch schon mal gehabt hätten sie theoretisch das ganze auch noch mit zettel
maßnahmen durchführen können aber da ging es wahrscheinlich auch um entscheidungen die für sie etwas positive ausgefallen sind deswegen haben sich da mühe gegeben und hier ging es im wesentlichen darum zu verhindern dass der chef gestürzt wird
da kann man jetzt alle möglichen verschwörungstheorien aufmachen das das tue ich nicht ich erwähne diese ganze geschichte einfach nur deshalb also erstens wir haben 's ja schon oft gesagt.
War computer generell schlechte idee voting mag ja ein tolle firma sein und so weiter,
keine ahnung weiß ich nicht kenne ich nicht lustigerweise formulieren sie ja dann irgendwie auf ihrer webseite auch immer wenn's ums abstimmen geht so.
Benutzen sie auch ab und zu mal das wort umfragen ja das ist so in etwa die qualität.
Also man muss schon noch einmal von dieser website zitieren,
weil diesen kontext muss der muss schon hier gegeben werden also laut firma watching technik die also jetzt hier ne also was die hier bauen ist ja effektiv ein triviale system man gibt ein paar also ein umfrage system.
Ein umfrage system das ergänzt wurde um ein paar zettelchen auf den coach den von menschen mit denen ist man wahlberechtigt die werden zufällig verteilt.
Und jetzt führen sie im prinzip das argument an dadurch dass ihr jetzt hier quasi dieses ding eingegeben hast,
bist du wahlberechtigt und jetzt kannst du an dieser umfrage teilnehmen eine wahl ist ja auch nicht viel anderes als eine umfrage unter berechtigten mit dem mit klaren beschränkungen wie oft jede berechtigte person gefragt werden darf und so weiter und dem,
unschön konsequenzen die so eine wahl nach sich bringt sie jetzt zum beispiel hier ursula von der leyen,
sie sagen auf ihrer webseite mit voting tech können sie als veranstalter sicher sein dass alle stimmen bei ihrer anonymen umfrage oder wahl gezählt werden wurden.
Die wähler benötigen keine computer technischen kenntnisse um die wahl nachvollziehen zu können sie haben
alle teilen so haben alle teilnehmer die möglichkeit die wesentlichen schritte der wahl handlung sowie die ergebnisse ermittlung zuverlässig und ohne besondere sachkenntnis zu prüfen und da ist natürlich bei mir sofort die klingel angegangen denn das ist
ein direktes zitat aus dem wahlkreis computer urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichtes zweitausendneun auch hier in logbuch netz politik
behandelt worden.
Indem es darum ging dürfen computer bei wahlen eingesetzt werden und die wenn du das jetzt aufruft das war computer urteil bundesverfassungsgericht zweitausendneun.
Lautet
das ist ja da gibt's eine lange begründung aber dann gibt's den urteilsspruch dass es erstens der grundsatz der öffentlichkeit der wahl aus artikel achtunddreißig in verbindung mit artikel zwanzig absatz eins und absatz zwei grundgesetz gebietet.
Dass alle wesentliche schritte der wahl öffentlicher überprüfbar bereit unterliegen soweit nicht andere verfassungsrechtliche belange eine ausnahme rechtfertigen zweitens jetzt kommt das der quasi der urteilsspruch,
beim einsatz elektronischer wahl geräte müssen die wesentlichen schritte der wahl handlung
und der ergebnis übermittlung vom bürger zuverlässig und ohne besondere sachkenntnis überprüft werden können das heißt sie haben ein plagiate aus dem urteil dass genau ihr scheiß system verbietet weil was ist nämlich nicht
hat was es nämlich nicht hat ist dass du als wähler eine bescheinigung bekommst dass du.
Gewählt hast und deine stimme wirklich gezählt wurde da steht ja nachher nur das ergebnis du kannst aber nicht einsehen okay hier das habe ich,
ich kann jetzt in dieser sekunde sehen ja da ist meine stimme,
und sie wurde gezählt einige systeme machen das zum beispiel versuchen sowas wie das sie dann sagen okay wir geben dir einen prüft code und du kannst nachher in den wahlergebnissen sehen dass dein prüft code da drin ist ne und dann sagen sie ja ok guck mal hier sind fünf hundertzwölf prüft kurz und jeder
bekommen ne dass und das amüsante ist,
natürlich kannst du dann trotzdem trivial noch eine wahl fälschen indem du bei was weiß ich fünfhundertzehn stimmen die jetzt hier abgegeben werden konnten beim slash dreiundzwanzig weil sie nicht fünf hundertzwölf war die null und die zweihundertfünfundfünfzig kannst du nicht nehmen,
deswegen sind fünfhundertzehn wahl ermöglichte menschen die jetzt hier ihre stimme abgeben wenn du jetzt einfach.
Mehrere davon den gleichen code gibst wenn sie das gleiche gewählt haben dann sehen sie nachher die anzahl stimmen
sehen auch ihren code und sagen ja mein code ist dabei aber du hast natürlich noch diese suppe dieses sub set an die du einfach dazu getan hast weil du einigen eine mehrfach gegeben hast das heißt dieser der einfache schritt zu sehen meine stimme wurde gezählt,
und zwar richtig der ist eben genau bei diesem system nicht gegeben und der ist bei dem unfall system gegeben wo du nämlich weiß da ist die urne,
da ist ein siegel drauf da ist mein zettel drin jetzt gucke ich mir an wie die urne aufgemacht wird ich weiß zwar nicht welcher dieser zettel es ist der da jetzt gezählt wird,
hi ich bin von der afd und hab den mit namen unterschrieben wichtig immer dran denken und dann
also dieser teil ist eben genau nicht ne die wesentlichen schritte der wahl handlung und der ergebnisse ermittlung sind nicht zuverlässig und nicht ohne besondere sachkenntnis zu überprüfen genau deswegen schreiben sie das,
ja genau deswegen schreiben sie das dass es so wäre damit,
damit du den scheiß benutzt es ist eben nicht so ich glaube jetzt nicht dass der vfb stuttgart oder wie die heißen ausgerechnet ihre wahlen da fälschen will aber immerhin sie sind auch nicht so weit gekommen dass es können.
Es wäre interessanterweise diese abstimmung die es ging war noch nicht mal zwingend anonym also die hat man hätte auch einfach kästchen hoch halten können es hätte auch funktioniert wenn man entsprechendes personal gehabt hätte sie zu zählen,
und wenn 's halt geheim sein soll klar ohne funktioniert sie hatten aber in dem moment auch keinen plan b auf dieser veranstaltung das heißt die waren nicht in der lage auf ein anderes system umzuschalten in dem moment wo ihr bevorzugtes system nicht funktioniert
was sagen wir mal ein bisschen also.
Es ist ja auch vor allem unsere position und das wird auch schön in ich habe glaube ich auch schon paar mal erwähnt gemacht zum ball computer urteil wo das ja ausführlich nochmal dargelegt wurde und,
daraus lässt sich auch ganz gut ablesen diese hürden dieses bundesverfassungsgericht sind nicht erfüllbar.
Ja also das das ist halt eigentlich der kern also sie sind nicht verboten war computer sind nicht verboten worden für bundestagsabgeordnete übung weil sie verboten wurden sondern die hürden wurden so hoch aufgestellt dass ihr einfach technisch nicht,
lieferbar natürlich gibt es immer noch genug leute die eben hier firma voting tisch oder wer auch immer ja die dann irgendwie wieder anfangen von man muss auch modern sein und mit der zeit gehen und überhaupt immer wieder mit diesen argumenten kommen,
aber es geht halt nicht man kann nicht zuschauen und man kann auch dieser app nicht zuschauen du weißt nicht welche software habe ich da was was tut die,
die meinen wunsch als solche überhaupt berücksichtigt oder hat sie nicht einfach irgendeine andere information überliefert wie soll ich's feststellen können und in dem moment wo man feststellen kann ist halt irgendein anderes prinzip dieser wahl,
gefährdet also liebe.
Fans und mitglieder des vfb stuttgart ich würde euch für die nächste mitgliederversammlung mal empfehlen diesen teil
mal wieder komplett zu ändern und elektronische abstimmung einfach mal komplett sein zu lassen weil ihr braucht eben bergab und wenn ihr im becker
brauchte den aufwand dafür treffen was habt ihr den aufwand schon gemacht da könnt ihr euch irgendwie das setup des wähler als einfach mal komplett sparen mag ja alles irgendwie ganz modern sein und so ihr werdet sicherlich noch häufiger in solchen situationen kommen wo es wirklich
um kritische entscheidung geht und selbst wenn ein system die richtige entscheidung herbeigeführt ja also ich sage ja nicht,
das wäre jetzt falsch gewesen ich sag nur keiner kann es überprüfen ob es so war.
Und genau das schafft er dann wiederum den boden dass die leute halt einfach,
ja sich auch zurecht darüber aufregen und sagen naja wenn ich nicht wenn ich nicht überprüfen kann wenn ich sicher sein kann dass es so wahr steht dieser verdacht immer im raum,
und das schafft halt unfrieden das schafft auch keinerlei basis für gewählte personen,
ja die ja dann sozusagen auch mit diesem mal los immer herumreden müssen dass sie unter umständen eben nicht legitim waren und keiner kann es ihnen bestätigen selbst wenn es so war.
Das ist das problem.
Xy wurde mit hilfe einer app gewählt wahl zweiter klasse.
Das kommt kurz nach abwahl kommt etwa.
Das ist richtig zweite war ein präsident zweiter wahl.
Ja jetzt ist er ja eh zurückgetreten weil das ganze dilemma der letzten endes auch mit zu verantworten und was halt alles nicht mehr haltbar von daher ist es vielleicht sogar ganz gut gelaufen jetzt wünsche ich dir,
stuttgart sich irgendwie mal wieder dass es sich wieder klar kriegen nein.
Facebook fünf milliarden dollar strafe zack.
Podcast aktivieren.
Aktienkurs hoch.
Na ja fünf milliarden dollar ist schon eine menge also das ist.
Das ist die höchste strafe die die f c jemals vergeben hat ich glaube sie haben google mal irgendwie zweiundzwanzig komma fünf millionen us-dollar strafe aufgeräumt
vor sieben jahren millionen und wir reden jetzt von fünf milliarden das sind größenordnungen mehr.
Worum ging's naja mehrere zehn millionen facebook nutzer sind in den,
wir haben ihre persönlichen daten plötzlich in den händen von cambridge analytica wiedergefunden wir,
erinnern uns an diesem diese skandal unternehmen im kontext brexit im kontext trump wahl,
und,
die einerseits erleichtert durch facebook eines andererseits aber auch unter verletzung sage ich mal von vereinbarungen die sie mit facebook hatten.
An massenhaft nutzerdaten gekommen sind und diese genutzt haben um zielgruppen orientierte wahlkampagne zu fahren und,
dass das ist ein verstoß gegen die zweitausendelf erlassen datenschutz
richtlinie der fc der sich facebook unterworfen hat und wo facebook sich verpflichtet hat daten nur nach ausdrückliche zustimmung an dritte weiterzugeben und dann hat das die fc also gesagt okay wir müssen uns mal hier,
wir müssen uns jetzt mal irgendwie
streiten und euch eine strafe aufdrücken facebook hat gesagt na was haltet ihr denn von fünf milliarden und die fc mit fünf personen besetzt hat dann drei zu zwei abgestimmt hat gesagt ja okay die strafe ist in ordnung.
Wäre also jetzt die die höchste strafe für ein datenschutz vergehen,
die von der fc jemals erlassen wurde wie gesagt bisher haben sie zweiundzwanzig einhalb millionen als strafe mal von google geholt das ist lange her man denkt sich oh krass okay da hat jetzt facebook aber mal richtig gelitten tja,
der zugewinn in aktienkurs von facebook nach dieser nachricht war eins komma acht prozent und diese,
eins komma acht prozent sind also natürlich bei facebook allein so viel das ist mehr ist.
Als diese fünf milliarden die sie an strafe haben das heißt der der wert.
Aber aktien.
Wenn ich den satz kurz zu ende.
Sehr kalt.
Der wert gewinn von facebook an der börse ist jetzt einmal hochgegangen der,
ist aber natürlich für facebook nicht wirklich realisierbar zeigt aber effektiv die erleichterung der märkte dass die strafe nicht höher war und das ist eigentlich der ausdruck für die macht,
dieses unternehmens ja wenn du eine wenn du eine strafe bekommst und die ist quasi gering.
Derart gering dass das für alle informierten anleger rennen und anleger effektiv zu gesagt er kann okay die ist geringer dies geringer als hätte ausfallen können und die so gering dass sie,
sag ich mal die operative tät,
dieses geschäfts nicht nachhaltig schädigen wird sondern es ist eher so ein aufatmen unter dem ding ist jetzt auch ein strich wir sind die schlechten nachrichten,
cambridge analytica los wir zahlen jetzt mal hier unsere fünf milliarden und dann atmen eben atmete der markt hier offenbar fröhlich,
auf finde ich auch interessant ne.
Also facebook hatte wohl selber drei milliarden erwartet oder maximal erwartet das richtig sehe.
Ja die hatten weniger dafür zurückgehalten aber ja,
aber ist ja klar die haben ja alle seine verhandlungen du sagst ja immer am ende so billig kann ich den golf nicht geben was tausend euro für pfui guck mal hier im saal kappe fehlt.
Ich hab gehört nur.
Warum hab ich grade wieder leben des bryan irgendwie von meinem inneren auge.
Fünf milliarden schicke.
Trotzdem man sieht ein trend der ganz interessant es geht jetzt so langsam ein bisschen los mit diesen strafzahlungen so und.
Immer noch nicht ganz so sicher dass das jetzt komplett wirkungsvoll frei ist mag sein dass der optimismus bei den facebook anlegern,
davon noch nicht unmittelbar betroffen ist und dass wir der meinung sind dass wir ja nur zehn prozent des jahres gewinnst macht ja nix bleibt ja noch genug übrig ja wir wissen alle sehr aktienmarkt funktioniert nach anderen,
regelt nämlich dieses wird es facebook langfristig schaden.
Genau und das ist offensichtlich hier nicht das ne das ist genau das ist der der.
Das heißt aber nicht dass die recht haben heißt nur dass das jetzt gerade noch der mindset.
Ja ja aber das ist trotzdem schon ein bisschen besorgniserregend.
Tschüss.
Da gab's noch theater,
um ip codes in facebook bildern großes großes thema und fragst du dich auch manchmal immer wenn wir das thema schon bei bei for ps irgendwie kommt dann hast du
jetzt nicht unbedingt so viel aussicht dass es jetzt besonders vertiefen ist wenn es jetzt eben um.
Cyber oder netz politik oder sowas geht es da einfach nicht so unbedingt das große spezial medium.
Und zwar geht es darum dass jemandem aufgefallen ist dass wenn er eine bilddatei auf facebook hochläd und sie dann wieder runter lädt.
In den metadaten der datei oben eine neue institution steht nämlich ein,
ein relativ langer zeichen wert.
Könnte sagen ein kleiner fingerabdruck und also eine ein ein wasserzeichen in der datei die facebook quasi dem bild hinzugefügt hat und die.
Tun das natürlich wahrscheinlich aus verschiedenen gründen ich gehe davon aus dass es ein,
feld ist wo sie sagen dann wurde dieses bild zum ersten mal hochgeladen original trends mission referenz also sie sie sagen wir haben dieses bild.
Dann und dann erhalten.
Und können quasi dadurch da dieses das jetzt in der datei drin ist und du würdest es noch einmal hochladen dann könnte facebook quasi sofort sehen ach wir haben da schon unser water markt drin.
Der bläht also gerade wahrscheinlich nochmal das bild hoch was xy schonmal hochgeladen hat wir können,
zum beispiel daraus folgendes wissen ableiten erstens wir müssen das hochgeladen bild gar nicht speichern wir können einfach das,
bild referenzen was wir eh schon hatten zweitens wir wissen jetzt dass x y dieses bild runtergeladen hat und und und das sind schon da die quelle für sein bild hat das können natürlich dann zum beispiel auch über instagram machen und so weiter.
Und haben so quasi weitere tracking informationen es wurde
von von von diesem typ der es getwittert hat irgendwie als die ein shopping level of tracking bezeichnet von fox titelte dann facebook ads hinten codes track
fotos auch das natürlich ne,
ein neuer skandal über den sich jetzt alle irgendwie beschäftigen sagen meine güte ist ja wahnsinn was sie tun und ich finde das ehrlich gesagt.
Interessant dass das so ein großes thema ist weil,
erstens das ist schon lange bekannt als facebook dieses feature implementiert hat gab es irgendwie in facebook community forum irgendwie die frage so ey was ist da steht jetzt was drin was ist das ja das ist also eine nicht eine nicht.
Ist nicht eine nicht bekannte information ist eine bekannte information schon länger und es ist facebook als
die tracken alles die wollen wir in geld die wollen wir die neue die wollen deine neue notenbank so ungefähr sein fürs internet die werden jede einzelne informationen die du ihnen gibst
bis auf maximum ausnutzen bis aufs maximum tracken und bis auf maximum
sortieren und für ihre monetarisieren übung nutzen und die,
geringste sorge der hass ist das ein bild wenn du es dort runter lädst ein eine markierung von denen enthält dass es von ihnen kommt falls du es nochmal hochladen würdest,
find ich tatsächlich also finde ich wirklich.
Bei weitem nicht so also es ist seit facebook ne also ungefähr so wie ich jetzt irgendwie darüber.
Keine ahnung darüber aufzuregen dass das das eine armee pistolen hat der die haben sogar noch ein messer im stiefel stecken ist ja ein wahnsinn ne die haben zwar panzer und aber ein messer im stiefel shopping ja das finde ich wirklich,
ja ja.
Es fügte gesamt problematik facebook jetzt nicht mehr viel hinzu was mal so.
Genau doch tim das jetzt der tropfen der das wasser zu darüber stirbt facebook jetzt darüber ist alles nein.
Oh mann.
Ja hier kommt die gute nachricht wir haben eine.
Ja je nachdem wie der brexit verläuft die neue britische fünfzig pfund note.
Wird touring als das content von elend touring tragen.
Der sommer irre oder.
Fisch okay.
Hat die bank of england gesagt ähm und sie werden also jetzt touring,
auf die fünfzig pfund note drucken das ist aus verschiedenen gründen eine ganz besondere,
gehst oder ein ein besonderes event erstens weil er mehr oder weniger der vater der der informatik ist und der vater der künstlichen intelligenz und ein,
ein genau und der,
ein kriegs hält der ein sehr signifikant ein anteil daran hatte dass die alle ihre kräfte dem nazi terror ein ende,
bereiten konnten indem sie die mama geknackt haben und auch weil er von seinem.
Von seinem heimatland zeit seines lebens nicht dafür wirklich anerkannt wurde,
stattdessen wurde er wegen seiner homosexualität verfolgt die haben glaube ich dann diese,
menschen unwürdigen therapien da aufzwingen wollen haben ihn letztendlich in den in den suizid getrieben ziemlich unappetitlich geschichte erst vor wenigen jahren hat das war david camera
glaube ich dann nochmal die offizielle also eine offizielle entschuldigung schuld an erkenntnis.
Also der der royal pardon wurde natürlich von der königin dann ausgesprochen aber angestrebt wurde es von gott.
Und ja.
Zweitausendneun grund brown äh hat sich offiziell entschuldigt und dann zweitausenddreizehn die queen und damit war es dann sozusagen.
Offiziell ne also royal paten ja das ist insofern ganz bemerkenswert.
Wie schon gesagt soll sich britannien ruhig mal ihre äh verdienste gegen nazis erinnern weil könnten sie jetzt ganz gut brauchen.
Ja
dann fand ich noch sehr interessant das wollte ich noch kurz erwähnen dass es eine studie dass jetzt eine eine studie durchgeführt wurde die sich quasi mit der thematik
fake-news auseinandergesetzt hat,
und quasi angestrebt hat als eine studie der university of cambridge die ein online spiel entwickelt haben.
Und bei diesem spiel geht es darum quasi mit strategien der
falsche informationen im internet zu arbeiten also du bist da quasi selber so ein ein troll und fake news verteiler also du bist du schlüpft in die andere rolle und ließ bei diesem
lernst bei diesem spiel eben dann mit mit fake news zu agieren deine gegner zu diskreditieren verschwörungstheorien hervorzubringen zu treuen zu polarisieren und so weiter so du lernst das handwerk,
wie man ein soziales netzwerk und eine öffentlichkeit medial vergiftet.
Und dann hat sich quasi weiterhin im weiteren test haben sie das gesehen dass die menschen die dort gut abschließen auch eine bessere fähigkeit entwickeln gefälschte twitter nachrichten,
als solche zu erkennen,
die idee ist also hier wir impfen die leute gegen gegen ihre anfälligkeit für fake news in denen indem wir sie spielerisch.
Die mechanismen der verbreitung lernen lassen und das finde ich sehr sehr erstens hoffnungsvoll,
also halte ich für auf eine gewisse weise einleuchtend dass so etwas funktionieren könnte und gib mir auch ein bisschen hoffnung,
weil das sich auch mit anderen erfahrungen in meinem leben schilder bedeckt nämlich dass du,
das ungemein vor dem du dich schützen willst eben am besten abwärts wenn du es verstehst,
ja das ist in der it-sicherheit das größte natürlich naheliegendste
konzept wenn du dich effektiv verteidigen willst musst du verstehen wie der angreifer funktioniert und genau das scheint sich ja hier dann auch im nachdenken.
Über medien wahrheiten und medien realitäten wieder zu spiegeln das finde ich interessant,
und fühle mich irgendwie mit hoffnung dass wir so vielleicht,
ein ein ansatz gefunden haben in der in der psychologie der im prinzip wie häufig übrigens in der paradoxen intervention besteht also eigentlich etwas wo du,
vielleicht auf anhieb vermuten würdest dass das genau das gegenteil als effekt hat,
und hier aber tatsächlich eine einsicht damit einhergeht.
Die menschen dann immunität viert oder darin schuld besser auf fakenews.
Achtung zu achten und nicht irgendwie so ein schuss,
zu zu glauben den hans-georg maaßen oder irgendein anderer rechter irre veröffentlicht.
Sehr spielerische ansatz meint es ja schon so hier ne security ist auch extrem wichtig eben diese angriff szenarien,
man könnte auch argumentieren dass die hacker szene zum beispiel auch ganz gut beweis dass die leute die sich damit auch
lange zeit auf so einer spielerischen ebene beschäftigen und sagen damit spaß am gerät rangehen auch ein viel vollständiges oder resilient ihres verständnis dieser mechaniken haben weil sie es einfach
über solche spiele mechanismen durch spaß orientierte auseinandersetzung damit verinnerlicht haben.
Das ist auch noch so eine halbe.
Schlecht ist auch schon bei anderthalb.
Läuft ja richtig ja ja immer noch haben wir noch was haben noch äh.
Ja wir lösen wir hätten ja noch termine.
Übrigens kennst du stranger things.
Hier ist eine ja ab ich gehört von.
Die staffel drei ist jetzt raus und es muss in der ersten oder zweiten folge sein.
Wo die ins kino gehen da müsst ihr mal auf die melodie acht.
Ja damit kommen wir zu den terminen womit geht's los mit der frost korn vielleicht die frost corn.
Eine seit vielen jahren etablierte veranstaltung findet immer jährlich in sankt augustin statt an der hochschule
rein sieg dieses jahr stehen zwei konferenz tage am zehnten und elften august zweitausendneunzehn an in acht höher seelen,
bietet die frost kann ein reichhaltiges und abwechslungsreiches vortrags programm freie software open source das steht hier im vordergrund und dort,
kann man ja daran teilnehmen.
Und zwar kostenlos.
Es war kostenlos so sieht's aus.
Und am achten und neunten november das ist also noch etwas hin in lübeck findet wieder die neid,
open statt genug und das geht am freitagabend los ab siebzehn uhr dreißig im audimax der uni lübeck und am samstag,
geht's ab vierzehn uhr am gleichen ort weiter warum erwähnen wir das jetzt schon weil der fcb geöffnet hat,
der geht noch bis zum dritten oktober aber ihr könnt da jetzt schon eure vorträge,
einreichen und eure vorschläge was ihr denn an der neid open stage beitragen möchtet in lübeck.
Ja dann gibt's da noch so eine andere veranstaltung die jetzt auch relativ bald stattfindet nämlich ende august das ist natürlich das chaos communication camp,
und wie gerne würden wir euch
hier berichten dass er nur hier auf diesen einen link klicken müsst wenn ihr unbedingt dabei sein würdet und wir hätten wahrscheinlich auch schon stundenlang in anderen anderen sendungen vorher
zeit damit verbracht euch nochmal nahe zu legen wie schön ist doch da ist und wie toll es doch wäre wenn ihr alle dahin kommt aber leider,
können wir euch da keine hoffnung machen denn diese veranstaltung ist komplett ausgebucht und ausverkauft,
obwohl es trotzdem noch viele tausend teilnehmer dorthin geschafft werden mehr kapazität,
hat das veranstaltungsgelände schlicht nicht und von daher gilt für viele leider dieser traurige spruch wir müssen leider draußen bleiben.
Ja es gibt wirklich keine tickets mehr und das problem werden wir dann denke ich in den bei der nächsten integration des camps berücksichtigen wenn uns überlegen,
aufgestellt sein muss um mehr menschen eine,
teilnahme zu ermöglichen aber bis dahin sind eben leider vier jahre und,
jetzt müssen wir erstmal dieses camp veranstalten trotzdem wird's natürlich inhaltlich auch wieder gestreamt,
das heißt ihr könnt ohne stream und die die vorträge die dort stattfinden verfolgen wir haben jetzt auch das design release,
mit einem schönen animationsfilm video von sven trafo rama der gestalter für das diesjährige camp und den link,
wenn ihr auch wirklich zum camp geht macht einfach spaß und.
Für diejenigen die zum camp gehen jetzt kommen auch langsam so die die die villages heißt es ja auf dem camp die villages die ihre eigenen,
bühnen und programme gestalten so zum beispiel das monkey village das aus so verschiedenen,
verschiedenen hacker spaces sich zusammensetzt ich denke primär berlin und karlsruhe aber es sind noch weitere daran beteiligt nämlich
also cb chaos computer berlin carlos und in leipzig die vollgas kuh und aus karlsruhe die entropy die also ein dezentralen vortrags und
party flora schaffen möchten und dafür ihren csu eröffnet haben bis zum siebenundzwanzigsten siebzehn siebenundzwanzigsten siebten könnt ihr dort dinge einreichen.
Beachtet dabei aber das geht nur dann wenn ihr auch ein ticket zur veranstaltung.
Ende des jahres ist dann wieder kongress da sollte sich die situation entsprechend entspannter darstellen ja und wie schon gesagt.
Zukünftige camps sicherlich
jeweils das zweite mal eine denselben ort sozusagen gespielt und hat sich immer wieder gezeigt am zweiten mal ist man dann irgendwie durch mit der location von daher steht da ohnehin ein ortswechsel an.
Ich finde es immer schön tim was du so für themen an schneidest wenn wenn wenn alles so kreativ in der arbeit stehen so ja location wechseln aber leider hat tim damit meistens recht gehabt.
Das ist so ein bisschen mein schon immer meine aufgabe gewesen immer schon über die nächste veranstaltung nachdenken ja das bringt uns als ende der sendung.
Ja es ist so schön ende der sendung ist auch schön.
Willst du noch was sagen.
Weiß ich nicht so genau wissen sie auch nochmal unterhalten wie wir das so mit dem camp halten wollen.
Ja ich dachte wir reichen hier bei monkey schön ein ja klar klar alter könnte es ja immer noch ablehnen.
Klar klein wa ja schau mal.
Dunkel musik wird er auch eine.
Aber man kann auf jeden fall trotzdem nur teil dem remote ne also auch wenn man jetzt nicht vor ort ist der inhalt wird auf jeden fall da sein und wenn auch ein wenig berichten.
Mir fällt jetzt auch nichts mehr ein bin jetzt wieder da und
jetzt ist noch so ein bisschen august ist nochmal so ein bisschen wird es noch ein bisschen schwierig werden glaub ich bei uns hier mit der sendung frequenz grade
vorlauf des camps ist glaube ich die zeitliche belastung insbesondere von dir relativ hoch,
also geht man nicht von zu viel sendungen aus wir machen euch jetzt einfach gerade mal keine versprechung orientiere was lustiges.
Ich komme sofort wieder aus unseren löchern.
Ja es ist ja tatsächlich so dass wir nie lange warten müssen.
Crazy wieder rechts überholt okay leute bis bald.
Ciao ciao achso danke frank vielen dank.
Bitte bitte bitte.
Ciao ciao.